all right we have new merch I want to
let you know to check out the new root
beer hoodie
if you want the coldest root beer then
get that ice cold drip uh and the four
piece enamel pen set we got a beautiful
little pen set right there you can put a
pin on somebody put it on somebody you
love or
put on somebody who needs love or put on
yourself
if you're even if you're burying
somebody hit them with that PIN
Cinema that be good to yourself all the
way to heaven
and you can check all that out at Theo
vonstore.com thank you so much for uh
wanting to support us and and wanting to
support the merch we do our best
today's guest is one of the most unique
men comedians
on Earth
he is a unique man
and um and that's that's a tough thing
to be sometimes uh but he has mastered
it he has a new special coming out on
Netflix called Baby J if you haven't
gotten to see his other specials you
should check them out
um today's guest is a talent
Mr John Mulaney
[Music]
sit and tell you my story
[Applause]
yeah man I'm just saving it because
we've never communicated really no
it's interesting not a bit isn't it
I'm still saving it because
that don't look ready yeah that's his
nickname don't look ready
oh no see he gets upset about you man
where his joking's at we're just kidding
he'll come back around
he's been losing weight too so he's
feeling more Sly aren't you what's that
you've been losing some weight recently
huh I'm trying I'm out there I'm hiking
yeah you look lean brother hiking is
tight you gonna do it hiking yeah it's
like free you just go like run you know
100 free
yeah that's Freedom isn't it hiking yeah
I don't know
where are you hiking
I'm not I do Fryman Canyon yeah with Dan
Levy oh you go with Dan yeah I only hike
with Dan oh wow he's even got a hike
with he's a good guy to hike with you
talk about money the entire time yeah
yeah he'll get you involved I've been
involved in countless things with Dan
I'm still in some what do you think I'm
in a class action with Dan somewhere
along the line oh for real did you get
involved in one of the flips he was
trying to do uh I don't think it was a
flip I don't it was some sneaker thing
it was like a
he has a lot of sneakers yeah tons he
has a whole special Closet in his home
for sneakers his wife doesn't have that
no but he does yeah and his wife yeah
yeah his wife doesn't have his wife
doesn't have anything and he has
everything he wants
yeah he's giving his wife nothing oh
it's three children oh
and he named him all after he named them
all Dan Levy yeah well Danny yeah and
then Danielle Danielle and then the
baby's just Dan yeah the little girl's
just Dan Levy I think you have to be at
that size you have to be at that size he
just bought a Porsche too did he really
so he's really going through it huh yeah
he paid 125 000. and his wife I think I
saw her on a bike or
I think crutches even crutches old ass
crutches not good crutches no I'm
talking I found the crutches at CVS and
I said you guys have a dumpster and she
said I could actually use those they
were just in the parking lot of the
Venture oh she had some real polio
Chopsticks when I saw her that sucks man
it sucks how Dan treats her uh
you know it's uh I'll put her on my
prayer list you know for sure yeah for
sure I'll put her at the top but it's
cool to be married to Dan Levy probably
oh you get to watch him drive to the
Improv in a bomber jacket and a Porsche
yeah and you get to watch him put all of
your money into his hair gel yeah
there's a lot of treatment going on and
it ain't just gel yeah I'll tell you
this
um did you ever get involved in a
sneaker business with him I got involved
I've been involved in some things with
Dan yeah he sends me links like these
Jordans are coming out today why don't
you buy 500 of them and then we'll sell
them yeah yeah yeah and he sends me off
right like players that have people have
like a lot of foreign players like uh
you know these vladi D box are coming
out you know they make up vladi Divas
it's a dress shoe you know it's a hard
shoe like a church shoe it's a Czech of
Slovakia yeah it's like a [__] Republic
like there would be a nice Brown loafer
yeah good for them yeah but yeah he's
Dan is a Dan is a talented guy oh he's
the greatest You Gotta Know Dan and he
is great his energy is all he always has
energy he always has energy
um his father's Abraham Lincoln addict
his father is an Abraham Lincoln addict
and uh we went to we were doing a show
in Springfield Illinois
uh this winter and we went to Lincoln's
grave really yeah just basically for
Elliott Levy yeah
you know when
you like to salute our First Responders
and no one responded
like there on that you know he was like
a first responder to slavery kind of in
a way I think wasn't he there were
probably some people before him who had
thoughts on it but he was definitely out
there yeah he was like as far as our
history books tell us he was kind of
like one of the guys out there like hey
yeah for real yeah
he was like an EMT kind of for slavery
he was an absolute EMT he did CPR in
this country this country was being
ripped apart this country was dragged
under a car yeah and he did CPR on it
let's see because he would do CPR on
someone who's dragged under her yeah uh
John Mulaney thanks for hanging out man
thanks for having me it's nice to meet
you yeah you too man we've never met we
saw each other in passing at The Improv
the other day that was the first time I
think I might have like we might have
crossed paths at the store once yeah but
I think it was at the Improv maybe two
months ago dude thanks for all your um
thanks for all your amazing comedy man
it's thanks for yours you are really
interesting to watch I love like this
other you have like this you're doing
your act it's non-stop right like I feel
like when I watch you I get my money's
worth you know oh thank you that's very
nice because it's like you're there's
almost a couple of things going on
sometimes you're telling a story or
you're telling a joke but you're also
commenting on it with like this and
that's how it's gonna be like it's
almost like there's this other character
and I can't really figure out what the
other character is
um like if if it comes from like
somebody in your life or if it's like a
do you know what I'm talking about at
all you mean the
um the way I sound on stage or some
you're talking about some other
ingredient and that's uh it's it's like
I'm watching a story it's almost like an
insider trading it's almost like this
other guy kind of pops out of you at the
same time and like kind of comments on
what's going on but it's like yeah
there's a part of there's someone out
there there's someone in me who doesn't
like the show yeah yeah
and who doesn't like who's embarrassed
maybe by the by the fact that he's doing
it
you know like when those multiple
personalities come out on an episode of
Law and Order yeah where they're like
Franklin's not here right now you know
you got to deal with that guy there's
someone in there who's like by the way I
[__] loathe telling this story
yes that's what it is it's this and I
just man it's so awesome to watch it's
so awesome that's nice you to say I
appreciate that thank you yeah thanks
because I'm like with that guy gonna pop
you know it's like I can't it almost
gives me something else to look forward
to while I'm enjoying the show you know
okay is that not only are is John
performing I'm watching but then there's
this other guy who's also part of John
who's gonna chime in every now and then
and tell me something dude I had a
psychiatrist when I was 17 and he told
me uh he goes half of you is this really
nice guy who wants to
you know do the right thing and be a
good person and the other half of you is
a gorilla whose sole purpose in life is
to destroy the first half
wow I think that I could see that
that's interesting
yeah I think I mean I definitely I feel
I could relate to a lot of that I don't
know if mine's a gorilla mine's more
probably a chimp maybe or oh yeah well
that's pretty scary too that's nothing
to shake a stick at oh a chimp can rip
your genitals off you don't throw them
500 feet but that's the story at least
yeah that's you know the birthday cake
story right the guy brought up
guy had two chimps brought one a
birthday cake and not the other which
seems like chimp 101 yeah both yeah you
got a double k then pop pop hands off
popped his ripped his hands off ripped
his feet off ripped his genitals off
threw them 500 feet oh I mean there's
lots of stories like that that's just
the one I've sort of but the worst part
is if your hands aren't there by the
time you get to your genitals you can't
even scoop them up yeah if you walk the
500 feet which you can't because you
don't have feet either it's a real he
was like you can't walk you can't do
anything you can't reproduce it was like
Bam Bam Bam no torso [__] he went for
the prize areas he went for the things
that really yeah they were wow that's it
right there oh yeah well that this looks
like yeah world's most horrific chimp
attacks
as Raging Apes rip off people's faces
hands and genitals
but I think say you get the the feet are
gone so he took the feet you just
Googled chimp birthday cake and that
came up okay so I have some of the
details correct yeah you were correct
okay that's fantastic
yeah I think if you take if you I'm
trying to think if somebody took my feet
off and I don't have any feet I think
you could still stick over there kind of
but that's you know like that Oscar
Pistorius die yeah but you're talking
about the first moment you lose your
feet you think you could stick it if you
don't look at the feet I think and you
stay out of that shock moment okay I
think and you just drive forward you
like we still have feet I feel like it
would take a while of the physical
therapy with the bars with the ballet
dancer bars on either side
stomping around and then I don't know I
just can't imagine that I could get up
and stump it over to my balls in the
pants
meanwhile I still got to sing happy
birthday because you're forgetting that
it's still a celebration for the one
chimp
so that's rude you know dude I was at a
uh I was at an AAA meeting right I'm in
a a good AAA and so I was at an AAA
meeting in person or over zoom in person
okay and some guy had only because there
were so many overzoom during them oh
yeah there were so many some meetings
stayed in Zoom yeah um
and I I some guy had a seizure in the
meeting right and this other lady was
her birthday in the meeting and they
sing Happy Birthday everybody yeah so
she like literally stepped over the guy
it was her birthday it was her moment it
was like I'm gonna get my cake you know
so
was it like were you all about to
present the cake and the guy had a
seizure yeah they're like uh you know uh
rondra got 76 years or something right
so she comes up and everybody's like
happy birthday and the guy seizures up
[__] man she's just like Steps over him
to me right like yeah yeah yeah oh she's
saying to me yeah I think nothing was
going to take her shine you know also so
it's interesting even on regular
birthdays I don't know people that sing
to me but I like when yeah I think it's
like well times have changed John I
think people want to it's about them now
that's a good point times have changed
but I think yeah dude I think if my feet
were gone if I don't know about that I'm
running on pure adrenaline you know they
lift cars off of children off of family
that's what they say yeah I mean I I
assume those stories are true I think
they have I think
look up like unique mom unique powers
Google you need yeah Google unique
powers from
mom adrenaline yeah oh now maybe that's
what we're starting to sell Search terms
there we go
how it's possible for an ordinary person
to lift a car
all right
in 2012 Lauren kornaki a 22 year old
woman
in no create a BBC account
[Music]
you can't look at anything anymore you
ever try to look up song lyrics you want
to [__] mess those websites out they
won't let you look at those either no
it's just like tons of it's just they're
the most insane A to Z lyrics or
whatever they're oh yeah they have more
pop-up ads it's like do you not want us
to know what the singer was saying right
yeah and now people are putting like
weird like you know everything I do I do
it for T-Mobile like people are playing
the songs wrong because the ads are
popping in yep you know yep
um it is interesting how there's so much
ads I think if I but I to go back to
this I think if you had pure adrenaline
going
and But the saddest part would be to get
to your own genitals and not be able to
pick you'd almost have to balance them
on your yeah it's like the end of The
Twilight Zone where the guy breaks his
glasses you finally get to your genitals
but you don't have hands
and you got to decide what you scoop up
with your mouth oh for real wow bro that
is crazy and then what yeah I don't know
what you take well you have to take your
gonads
because you want if you want to have a
family
yeah you have to see what kind of
condition I mean you have to make a
split second what kind of condition are
these and by the way I'm assuming the
chimp is making a beeline for you and
not at all done especially if you um if
you stuck it and stumped away
yeah that's true probably he's gonna be
right behind you he didn't mean to just
you know
God man it's so harrowing to think what
you would do in certain instances you
know and if you have the because I even
notice like
if I get like scared at night you know
yeah I'll even say like
is somebody there you know like
somebody's gonna be like
yeah you're lying in bed and you hear a
noise type skin yeah like I'll get you
know I mean I'm tough and everything but
I will also in addition to being tough I
will like go be like you know hey is
somebody there like I'll do like um
who's you know yeah yeah and like
they're gonna say something back like
I'm here you know burglar yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it's always a burglar
in my mind you know it's always that
kind of Home Alone s type of fella you
think it's someone coming in to steal
items and just hoping no one wakes up
and asks is anyone there yeah and you
just yeah
I think about home invasion
most of the day
yeah I mean
you do you ever yell I have a gun
no that's a good idea yeah
I have a gun
oh that sounded pretty with authority
right I have a gun now when you say
you're a tough guy see I would mess it
up when you say you're a tough guy in
them in that moment you're in your home
someone's coming in you don't know what
they're about do you feel tough
at first I don't right but then I have
to remember hey you are tough so then I
will be able to be tough tough meaning I
know how to fight do you do
um I'll go to like Jiu Jitsu classes
okay all right but not a ton though okay
just enough to like maybe
I'm a huge fan of it sure but I am a
like I'm a one stripe white belt and
there are
four-year-olds that are that or
seven-year-olds probably not four
but uh you know so it's not it's not an
insane thing to get but I mean
I do know that once there's once so say
say there's somebody I hear something
right yeah I get out of bed
I go over and then I realize the
scariest part is you have to turn a
corner in your home that's oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so from now on Ice turn
and I go like I'll turn and be like hey
you know I will turn like
I'm here or something like that like
something so that if there is somebody
they're about to attack me they're not
just gonna get onto something that's
like sinking away yeah
I had a um a t-shirt I bought at Kanye
West Life of Pablo tour it was a like a
double XL airbrush t-shirt and on the
front it had a airbrush painting of
donde West okay and on the back it had
an airbrush painting of Robert
Kardashian Kim Kardashian's late father
and O.J Simpson's attorney
I was at home
um a few years back and it was New
Year's it was a couple days after New
Year's and I had a New Year's party
where there'd been balloons and [__] so
the the but the house was still you know
uh messy from it
um middle of the night uh the alarm goes
off screaming alarm like the loud ass
someone just came in through the door
alarm oh so I get out [__] threadbare
boxers don't do West Robert Kardashian
t-shirt I reached behind the bed for my
Easton bat and it's not there oh I must
have been showing it off downstairs okay
so now I'm going I'm like I'm out in the
uh in the hallway and I'm like I gotta
Rush down the stairs which had two turns
to it oh God and I'm like I've got
nothing
except maybe the T-shirt to buy me some
time of confusion like if I jumped out
and you saw a big down to West and I
spun around and there was an equally big
Robert Kardashian and it said rest in
power you'd be like huh like that [__]
it'd give me a minute holy [__] that's a
really nice just a hologram show in my
exactly am I a Coachella or just like
wow that's a really nice way to pay
tribute to your parents right and then I
could [__] I don't know any but you
could do something I could do some Miss
Piggy like karate it's fine she would
fly through there and uh I go down and
it's pitch black and I'm just in the
darkness and right then a balloon
decides to lose just enough helium that
it floats down a big ass Yellow Balloon
floats down right in front of my face
I've never like it's an Asian guy is
more like
you haven't I've never been murdered by
a clown but I bet right before you're
murdered by a clown a big yellow balloon
and I said out loud not like this
I was so
existentially scared and it was I was
just like not not now
not like this
I love that man murdered by a clown in A
donde West Robert Kardashian what a way
to go though yeah I mean it'd be in the
paper you know summertime is knock
knocking on the door baby summertime I
hear the Heat
and our friends at Shady Rays have you
covered for the warm weather ahead with
premium polarized Shades at an
affordable price that's right Shady Rays
is an independent sunglass company that
offers a world class product
durable frames and extremely clear
optics for Outdoor Adventures
if you don't love your shady Rays
exchange for a new pair or return them
for free within 30 days there's no risk
when you shop their team always has your
back
exclusively for our listeners Shady Rays
is giving out their best deal of the
Season go to shadyraise.com and use code
Theo for 50 off two plus pairs of
polarized sunglasses try for yourself
the shades rated 5 Stars by over 250 000
people
that's right go to shadyraise.com and
use code Theo for 50 off two or more
pairs this episode is brought to you by
manscaped
and what a perfect time considering
April is testicular cancer awareness
month
to help raise awareness and to fundraise
for a good cause
manscaped is partnered up with the
testicular cancer society to remind you
to check your golden nuggets this month
for anything that's not so golden make
sure your nuts are good
that's right support a good cause and go
to manscape.com and use code Theo to get
20 off in free shipping
that's it
to help remind you guys
that they have the new special edition
purple TCS lawnmower 4.0 electric
waterproof trimmer whoo that's a lot
get 20 off in free shipping with code
Theo at manscaped.com that's 20 off in
free shipping with code Theo at
manscape.com make sure to spread the
news and tell your buddies to check
themselves in testicular Awareness Month
way to go
wow man there is you know it really is a
test of in those moments what happens
you know
there was a famous UFC fighter that's
got Lionheart Smith who's an amazing guy
um he's from Ohio and he got attacked in
the middle of the night at his home by a
guy on methamphetamines whoa and he said
it was the hardest fight he's ever been
in his life
it's just because he had that meth Never
Gonna Never Gonna Give You Up energy
yeah I think he had that yeah that meth
like Whitney Houston is that Whitney
Houston Never Gonna Give You Up no Never
Gonna Let You Down that's Rick Astley
okay oh is that what Rick Rolling is yes
okay yeah yeah that's how I know it yeah
interesting
um did you ever do methamphetamine
I never did man I never did I always
wanted to same did you ever smoke crack
uh no okay did you neither yeah
I didn't get to do Freebase I did I
smoke cocaine a couple you did yep and
the people smoke it out of
I you always see that kind of like glass
pipe with the smoke stains in it off a
foil
oh wow yeah
um I get one year sober tomorrow you do
yep congratulations thank you man holy
[__] not trying to make it about me but
please make it about you it's important
there's only two of us yeah
one year tomorrow oh congratulations a
lot of our listeners are
um people that struggle so yeah what's
been do you mind me asking you when I
saw you I probably saw you
two months ago and you told me you had
like 10 months oh yeah were you did you
take time off from working like what was
um during the pandemic you got super
during the pandemic I went to two
different rehabs wow and by December
2020 uh I was sober
um I mean I was in rehab then right
um but it was weird because it was this
during this kind of pause for everyone
right so what a blessing that had
happened then in some ways did it feel
like that did it feel like that I don't
man I was I gotta say I did not
experience the pandemic the same way
other people did I I don't know like I
was I was using a lot oh really and uh
I just it didn't feel like it didn't
feel like anything that different I I I
feel bad saying that
um yeah I mean you was very bad saying
that because it was been pretty hot you
must have been pretty yeah or into
getting high yeah you weren't even doing
the pandemic if you don't know there's
I'll say this I didn't know that uh the
nasal swab tests hurt
until uh well after I got sober okay and
then I got one not numbed up by cocaine
and I went ah
what are they I used to get him and I
was like what is everyone complaining
about yeah just don't feel like it
um did you so cocaine you liked cocaine
Xanax Klonopin Adderall Percocet
riddle in any kind of speed oh so all
that speed huh
um would you get I would get so scared
at night when I was high on cocaine
right yeah
that I would be like Googling what can I
take with cocaine to go to sleep
and that would take me so many hours to
I'd look at so many there'd be like you
get on these answer sites and people's
like you go to Florida yeah yeah I go to
quora right or whatever that is right
yeah yeah count hey count down from 60
and you'll be dead people would say
stuff like that and you're just like oh
my so you didn't have like because
that's the thing I I actually you didn't
take any downers I didn't take any
downers so I would lay there in misery I
would Google like can I go may I ask did
you know about downers
I guess I knew about him but I just had
never taken them and I was so scared to
mix something with cocaine because it
would kill me that's what I was fearful
that was your worry yeah
um I kind of thought if I if I didn't
have the right balance
yeah I was more like if I don't have
enough in the right amounts then
something bad could happen but as long
as I'm balancing coconateral with Xanax
and Klonopin I'll be justified I
remember I walked into my intervention I
just been to my drug dealers apartment
and I finally got the right balance oh
yeah one pocket all Adderall and Coke
one pocket all Xanax and I was like I
have
done it I reached equilibrium yeah open
the door and a bunch of people yeah it's
okay though were you high when you went
to Europe yes but I was insisting that I
hadn't used drugs in days I went look I
am sober right now look at me I am sober
right now I kept saying and were you
good enough to convince those people
that you were no I was pretty strung out
by then so it didn't I I I could present
really well for a long time yeah but I'd
reached a point where
um it was just off the rails I'm seeing
that about you you're a very good
presenter
um it's a yeah a a doctor at rehab was
like it scares me how good you are at
presenting like everything's fine wow
yeah
so were you
um when you got sober a year ago
tomorrow you were were you busy with all
this [__] you do I was just in my I was
like I was in my garage and I would
thought I was gonna just I was just
miserable I wasn't even using drugs
really I was drinking some I was burnt
out and exhausted but I just had no
program yeah and I was like literally I
was just crying and my brother I was
like man I just can't live I just I I
just can't live
like this and I know it sounds like such
a weak thing to say but that's just
where my mind was you know what do you
mean was that a weak thing to say
I don't know there's something about it
when you like look and you know that you
have food and you have shelter
to be in a space where you're like
to feel like something is wrong with you
that you can't
fix I guess or if you're just someone
who likes to have control and thinks you
manage well and you're capable there's
some real thing that feels like
almost weak and I I'm not saying it is
weak but it feels weak sometimes to be
like
something's wrong with me and I can't
there's nothing I can do about it I felt
like something's so wrong with me that I
have like
I've overrided
like because we're designed to survive
I'd overrided the desire to survive like
when you're like when when you want
pills and drugs more than you inherently
want to
like make it through the day that's
somewhat weird
reverse evolutionary [__] yeah yeah for
your brain to basically be able to run
the scenario and go we haven't slept in
four days we chained smoke we eat Sour
Patch Kids we'd never drink water we're
blowing tons of coke this isn't Gonna
Last and you go I think I think we're
gonna keep on I think we're gonna keep
doing this
um
so you were deep in uh how did you get
so deep in because I don't think anyone
would look at you and think this is the
Coke guy good that was the whole thing
um I mean I certainly tried to talk
about it on stage as having had like a
drug and alcohol problem but it just I
don't know yeah it didn't something
about me seems
so to me it's like well of course the
guy that seems like he has it all
together has the problem because that's
just like how life is that's Texas yeah
it's almost like this textbook yeah
um
but that's I I don't put that on other I
don't put that on you to be like how
come you didn't see it because I was I
also I really thought like
I really thought that I was doing life I
was able to achieve at life with the
drugs as opposed to In Spite of them it
took me a long time over the past couple
years to realize that I did well at what
I do in spite of drugs not because of
them wow yeah yeah because it would be
fun yeah from an outsider I would always
look at him and be like oh that guy yeah
drugs would not help that guy
like that guy is his own he is so unique
in his own way that anything to uh like
a a a base at or something or debase
that would only mess him up but I would
have thought I would have thought like
I'm delivering something people really
like and I think I'm delivering it
because I take two 30 milligram
Adderalls and then one z-bar and so I'm
really sharp but I don't seem jittery
and so I go on a podcast or I go on a
talk show and I'm just I'm delivering
and I'm giving people what I'm naturally
good at but I'm a little tired so I
can't naturally do it so it's okay it's
okay to take it's okay to rip open time
release Adderall and dump the beads down
my throat and then pop a Klonopin
because then I will get to the level
that I naturally am at like I just gotta
deliver what I'm good at and right now
we're running on a lean mixture and it
used to be easier but now it's harder so
whatever I'm putting in my body to get
to that is fine that's like a acceptable
you know acceptable
you're like your own you're like your
own Geppetto almost in a weird way let
me think about that
how do you
uh in what way like you were
because if you were kind of running if
you wanted to get yourself you were a
little burnt out you're trying to get
yourself to the place where everybody
loves you at and where you know you
operate best at so yeah I wanted to be
like I'd see myself
never see a oh that's something I see a
clip of me like I need to be like of
myself and be like I need to be like
that oh yeah how do I get I how that
guy's confident has a bunch of things to
say yeah how did he get the how did I
how did he have the thoughts oh yeah I
thought look man I miss my old self
sometimes you're you're using self no
just myself like a few years ago yeah
there was some yeah that's what I was
chasing something there was some moment
Maybe
you know like 2007 I didn't know what it
was but I was like I had some
electricity in my eyes yeah where you
know wow it's so I gotta get back to
that and I just got to get back to that
and I just got to get back to that yeah
I got somehow it'll happen somehow I'll
find the right amount
for real you know like I'm 100 serious I
that's
that yeah that's what I think all the
time I look at old things and I'm like
oh man I missed that guy yep that was a
yeah that's a really entertaining person
yeah and I don't even put it on I don't
even mean like and I and I people
demanded I'm not acting like
I couldn't have taken a break and you
know it's not like the audience demanded
this not at all it was what I wanted to
do that's what I wanted oh yeah I don't
yeah I don't get that perception yeah no
okay but it's interesting yeah I wanted
to get back to him I wanted to feel back
to myself I wanted to be like that guy
was so creative and original I know now
I think some of them take drugs because
you want to feel like you're 12 or 13
again
it's a little messed up it's a little
messed up but it also makes sense I
think if you for me some of that goes
back to
I think I know I felt like I I missed
out on some childhood so I part of me
wants to get back to that I think
there's some psycho uh psychology out on
it just missed out on like having some
moments of childhood that would have
felt more comfortable and fun okay
um but I think part of it is
I uh
I used to like the element of surprise
when people didn't know me uh-huh you
had an element of surprise to people
yeah and there were and there was
something that was
nice about that it was like
um
it made you be able to be the only one
who presented you to people yeah and
then as you get more popular I think is
the term that I'll use or where people
have seen more of you
um then there's some expectations or the
this the the thing of surprise which
made me feel like unique that I can just
be the controller of me yeah that goes
away because people have already seen
you and have some interpretation of you
and so I think
this all may sound really ego Monaco but
that bummed me out a little bit because
I think the only thing I ever felt like
I had when I was growing up was myself
okay and so I wanted to be able to
authentically present that as much as I
could yeah and um and that goes away as
you get more people have seen you does
that make any sense 100 okay I mean I
don't know what it means dude people
used to have stage names for a reason
because you know they could go home and
be like
you know Johnny Starlight is the guy on
stage John Mulaney is me the person who
I you know the person like I gotta say
I I don't
you know there's some real destructive
part of me that I've worked on a lot but
I wouldn't say I have low self-esteem
day-to-day which is a really nice thing
um and it doesn't seem like you do
either
so it it becomes like
you know I I like myself
um yeah if you like yourself and then
yourself is out there in the world and
it and they seem like you just gotta
think of them as two different things
I'm not saying this that articulately
people had stage names because they
could be like well that's something else
right that's not me that's not the
little kid I was right
yeah I think Natalie comes from like
those people would have fake names
because they'd read a review of
themselves and it wasn't their real name
so they'd be like oh that's not me right
that's a thing now we're so it's hard
now everybody knows everything about you
within reason yeah yeah I mean it's hard
to detach it's hard to keep some things
to yourself it's even hard to
yeah
um
yeah though I mean whatever whatever
people put out there is also right who
knows if it's real or not yeah but it's
like it used to be like um
like I remember we loved Michael Landon
growing up right we had drawings of them
and once a year yeah you have Highway to
Heaven behind you oh yeah we meaning
your family I mean it's whatever
whatever
political party builds that dude I'm
voting for him I'll tell you that you
know
um
uh he was dying through my whole
childhood it felt like like Michael
Landon like I just remember being a kid
and being at the supermarket and like
every National Inquirer was like Michael
Landon's final battle and I was just
like is this person I didn't even know
he was an actor I thought he might be
famously ill like just a guy in a jean
jacket who was always sick
um because I never saw Bonanza until
like it was on Nick at night and then
yeah
there he is God look at him
so what you were into Michael Landon
from we loved him from Little House on
the Prairie
you know what's crazy one of the first
times I learned about drug withdrawal
was from Little House on the Prairie oh
I know what episode you're talking about
yeah not [__] crazy that episode I
know nothing about Little House on the
Prairie but I saw that once I think
Michael Landon stays up with the kid
who's on opium and yeah sweats it out
it's like Basketball Diaries level it
really is in the middle of whatever the
hell else used to happen on that show
cook and stew or whatever Walnut Grove
yeah a lot of like I mean that's when
pink eye you would lose a twin the pink
eye
I remember one episode would be born
with pink eye and it was a real oh one
yeah there it is that's Albert Ingalls
right there he was addicted was that
that character so I know nothing about
the show was that that character's whole
deal was that he was a morphine addict
or was that just a special episode no he
was adopted and so he had this kind of
like uh interesting like
space he was always kind of could play
this Outsider character
um
but he he was a friend of their
daughter he was a friend of the
daughters okay Albert Ingalls you know I
saw Nelly Olsen one time at a Starbucks
she was the blonde on the show because
she was kind of like I really only know
the Opium episode but okay okay but
she's the daughter and I I was excited
yeah that's really cool I know she
wasn't excited to hear me tell her I saw
the little woman that uh the remember
the principal in Kindergarten Cop uh
uh she's smaller woman
um let me think her name's like Linda
not Linda ronstad huh no not Linda
Ronstadt the singer Linda Hunt Linda
Hunt thank you I saw her at Bristol
Farms I was excited there she is oh
remember she goes what did it feel like
to hit that SOB yeah
um anyway I saw her at Bristol Farms
that just made me I just thought of that
when you said you saw Nelly
Molson ianelli Olsen
um so why did you bring up Michael
Landon I'm sorry I took us we used to
love him and we would draw every year
mom would like usually at Easter
honestly we would draw a picture of him
and whoever like draw the best picture
would get like a candy or something you
and your siblings would do this yeah and
whoever would draw the best picture I'm
gonna get like a candy or something from
Mom and
um
and he was supposed to come to town one
year or something like at the
fairgrounds or something where'd you
grow up in Louisiana okay but something
happened there was like a storm or
something he couldn't come and
oh [__] oh yeah all the women's Hearts
were broken man mom went down there and
it was like our big like mom's gonna
meet him you know oh man did you guys
bring the pictures to show him no no we
didn't go
oh it was just like women only yeah
adults only Michael Landon meet and
greet at the county fair yeah
and I mean and I just remember Mom
coming home and it just was sad yeah for
him but yeah it just made me think you
couldn't know any more about an act or a
character at that point they were almost
just their character and yeah if you saw
some tabloids you could learn some stuff
behind them but you didn't it's hard to
even
now that I couldn't I didn't even know
about his career That's how little I
knew about Michael Landon I just thought
this man is battling cancer like on the
regular
in all denim yeah I thought Highway to
Heaven was I don't mean this like as a
joke like no not at all man I thought
Highway to Heaven was like not a
documentary but I just was it was like
he was always dying and then he had this
show called Highway to Heaven and I just
thought they were somehow I was like oh
this is just someone we're all watching
through go through the final stages of
Life yeah it turned out he had a big
acting career yeah yeah yeah
like this guy's in traffic to get to
heaven like how long yes yes yeah yeah
but yeah we missed I mean that was a
bummer for us when you look back so
whenever you start whenever you so were
you surprised that you were an addict or
did you know you were an addict
um I had like
Skin Deep self-awareness of like I have
a drug problem uh I'm I love drugs I
like them too much I don't like them the
way other people like them it's not like
oh that was fun let's do that again in
two weeks this was like I think I think
the plan for the morning should be to
get more of that
um I knew I liked them more than other
people but I it was but no not to the
depth that it was what do I mean to say
I had us I had a surface level awareness
and I would joke about that and and say
you know oh I got sober in 2005 which I
did but I slowly got back into
Pharmaceuticals over the next you know
13 14 years prescribed then not
prescribed or prescribed then abused but
prescribed then bought on the street
then everything were you buy them off of
Craigslist and stuff like that even no I
always thought that might be cops
smart
um
and it's depressed pills it's a lot of
like I have friends this was even before
I had an awareness that there might be
fakes out there like that yeah um I've
definitely bought Adderall a couple
times and snorted it and thought this is
what is this yeah oh I bought a whole
thing of something one time and did it
all and it wasn't it wasn't cocaine nope
no God ugh and I don't know what it is
and I still imagine one day I'm gonna
walk past a chemical and
and it's going to connect a little oh
you'll smell it or something you'll
smell a chemical and you remember that
that was what you bought he'd be like oh
it was me or something you know what I'm
saying yeah uh no it the um the
realization that I actually
had no control over this
took a long time wow
that's a hard thing for people to
convince it's a hard I mean I still
struggle sometimes even if I sit in a
meeting and
there's still part of me that doesn't
want to say I'm an alcoholic
yeah or an addict I to me I go it's more
complicated than that yeah like you
don't get it it's not
it's not that I'm like it's not that
just that cocaine's addictive and when I
do it I'm addicted it's it's a different
thing I use it in a different way and
the way I see it my relationship with it
it's just yeah I kind of have a romance
it's like a i romanticize it 100 I write
everything in my life me too yeah do you
think you're in a movie
no I don't I do think I'm in a like one
of those fun houses sometimes but the
fair is [__] closed you know oh wow
and it's because the storm came in and
Michael Landon came Michael Landon
canceled who was the first famous person
you ever met if Michael Landon canceled
that
um
let me think of who it was that's a
great question maybe saw
uh
probably the DARE officer at our school
but he wasn't like nationally famous but
he was how famous was he he was like the
biggest guy they ever made in the whole
world and what do you mean when the car
would pull up like I remember one time
he like shot people from the car he
couldn't get out of like the officer
vehicle or whatever he was a huge man he
was a oh he was a big fella he was an
obese man and
he and he would come to speak about dare
yeah and he got out of the car but uh
there were Tales of him at crimes where
he'd just pull up and just start popping
off you know because he couldn't at some
point he couldn't even get out of the
vehicle oh so he'd fire from the vehicle
and open fire so he was like uh in our
area he was pretty popular Ronald Reagan
um was his name no that'd be crazy it
also happened to be named Ronald Reagan
uh the first Fame I don't know there was
this uh like did you see Reagan
somewhere no but we built the tallest
statue of Ronald Reagan in our town whoa
he was supposed to come and he didn't
come wait a minute he you built the
tallest statue of Ronald Reagan in the
U.S yeah or in the world ten foot tall
look it up Zachary please tallest statue
of Ronald Ronald Reagan yeah Reagan
Covington Louisiana there you go God
damn
that's not a bad statue I thought they
did pretty good you know what I would do
if I was putting a photo on this website
as I'd show how tall it was
yeah as opposed to these close-ups it's
a great Point actually see it in a
cowboy shot and it's supposed to be real
bronze but that something that could be
a rumor but oh wow and there we go so
okay
look at the look at the oh whoa now
that's nice that's huge
yeah they did a good job uh Pistol Pete
Maravich was from our lived in our town
and so his sons went to our school Ian's
were they good at dribbling and stuff
they were good yeah they were good it's
a good movie that pistol piece it is
good yeah
um Ian Somerhalder do you know who that
is that sounds really familiar he's a
he's an actor can you look him up Ian
Somerhalder he went to our school and he
was like the most beautiful guy that
ever existed in the world
and he would just come to the first day
of school oh yeah yeah I do know oh that
guy's got light eyes like a husky does
yeah yeah like those dogs with the light
eyes oh yeah like Riff Raff would own
this guy
um but he uh he would come to school the
first day just so all the girls knew
that he was like in town and then just
go off and be like a supermodel but he
would always come the first day of
school oh so then you ditched the rest
of the you just be like I exist and then
he would ditch the rest of the year yeah
he was like a kind of no dummy no it was
oh he was smart he knew how to do it but
he was too almost too handsome to even
exist kind of you know like he was just
that Dracula handsome you know yeah I
remember as a kid not realizing that
people disliked Ronald Reagan like I I
remember being like that's the president
so Everyone likes him yeah and then this
kid in in class uh
Matt Murphy he told me Ronald Reagan
hates poor people and I said well that'd
be impossible because he's the president
and he's like the best person in the
world because he's why else would he be
the president yeah
I did not have nuanced political views
at that time yeah yeah me neither I
think yeah if I thought somebody was the
president then they this cared about
everybody yeah it was a it was an
outlandish charge yeah to go from I was
I was clocking him as best person in the
world now to find out he especially
doesn't care about poor people yeah you
know Morgan wallen's on tour
and so is uh suicide boys I love both of
them
uh Jesse Murphy's touring I like her
I like a lot of different bands and
performers
Parker McCollum all of that
and that reminds me actually seat geek
with over 28 million downloads seat geek
is the number one rated ticketing app
there are more than 70
000 events every single day on seat geek
including concerts Sports festivals and
more
for sports we got the NBA and NHL season
in full swing
for concerts Morgan Wallen Drake Beyonce
look
they put all the tickets across the web
in one place to make sure you're getting
a good deal at SeatGeek each ticket is
rated on a scale of one to ten so look
for the green dots green means good red
means bad
every ticket is backed by their buyer
guarantee and seat geek is the only site
that lets you return your tickets added
ahead of the event with swaps
and you know I came through for you guys
use my code Theo for twenty dollars off
tickets at SeatGeek that's 20 off your
first purchase with promo code Theo make
sure you click the link in the
description to download the app you know
what's free right now is gamer sups
that's it gamer sups
it's the best alternative to traditional
energy drinks and sugar loaded beverages
this is an alternative to those
gamer sups GG energy is a zero sugar
keto friendly source of caffeine that
gives you the energy you need
without worrying about a crash later no
crashing
gamer Subs has lots of cool flavors like
guacamole gamer fart 9000.
and titty milk and more that's right
claiming free samples is easy
just go to the link
gamersupps.gg
Theo Von which will take you
automatically to the free sample packs
that's it
you can get a free sample of gamer Subs
on their website but for the next 24
hours if you use code Theo vonnet check
out you will also get free shipping and
a custom theovan sticker for the first
thousand people to order the samples
that's right go to
uh
www.gamersups.gg theovan and use code
theovan to get free shipping on free
samples for the next 24 hours
I'm trying to think of who is the first
famous person that you met
um because you've run in some pretty
famous circles now well but as a kid
um
hmm
and you're from where you're from
Chicago Illinois oh wow yeah we grew up
in the city Mike Ditka maybe did you see
him
you know I'm trying to I feel like I saw
Chris cellio Jim McMahon somewhere yeah
yeah but I I can't
I I can't I can't Square it who was the
first I ever saw Jim McMahon Jim McMahon
or was he just so famous I felt like I
knew him that was a weird thing about
um growing up in Chicago
in the late 80s early 90s as we just
I just thought that wherever I was the
best basketball team would be like I
didn't I kind of associated it with my
own well yeah and having my own presence
and moved to LA wow that's crazy I was
just like well of course like my you
know and everywhere we would go on
vacation and people be like Chicago
Michael Jordan I'll be like yeah I know
like we got it we did it we got it we
got it covered and then you moved to LA
and then yeah and then I moved to New
York yeah well also the the Bulls just
you know they were so good 97 98.99 I
saw B.J Armstrong at my gym wonderful
wonderful guy and I love seeing him yeah
every time I see him I'm like I know
it's you and he's like you've told me
that seven times he's out here in L.A
yeah he's an agent I believe at a sports
agency
but um super nice guy I think if it's
Iowa or Iowa State for college but uh I
always doubt we get so excited seeing
him America loved that team though I
mean unless you were like in Cleveland
or New York
I met Barclay once or I met him twice
because he hosted Saturday Night Live a
couple times did he only host once no he
hosted twice but I was only there the
one time
um
and I asked him about the Dream Team
because we
you know with Barkley like we weren't
going to write together uh so Tuesday
night the host would walk around the
different offices and Simon Rich this
writer and I that worked together a lot
we just asked him we go what was the
Dream Team like and he went oh man he
goes if you ever get a chance to go to
the Olympics do it I was like okay I'll
make sure to but he told me he goes we
we would beat those guys by a hundred
points and then they'd ask for photos
wow he was like it was the greatest time
ever of anyone doing anything
that's awesome Larry Bird was on there
yeah John Starks Horace Grant made that
team member yes he did 92 David Robinson
Horace Grant made the team I'm pretty
sure David Robinson
Scottie Pippen I don't know if Horus
made it
you're right he didn't Scotty
yes Scotty Stockton Claude Drexler yeah
who always looked 55 somehow
Carl Malone
out of Louisiana Tech yeah he went to
Louisiana Tech he did Christian late and
was on there I wonder how interesting
that was for him
Christian Laettner
no Bobby Hurley he always looked like
the richest guy in the world you know he
had like the most he had uh it was a
haircut it was just a haircut thing yeah
yeah let's zoom in on later a little bit
he kind of had the most punchable face
in a weird way
which is a messed up term to use but he
had it man he had the most damn point
was it him or him or Christian ladies
right there yeah Christian Laettner you
got the magnifying glass right over him
he looks a little zooted out there yeah
dude I ended up did you ever have a
weird scenario because I had one like I
ended up in a taxi cab all right zooted
up man some girl where where do you mind
where were you living at this point I
was living out here okay and that's when
I kind of like I had a couple nights in
a row where I got really just just coked
out right and I started just
and then I was in New York one night and
a girl said something to me in a taxi
oh I tried to give her a smooch right
and I wasn't being aggressive or
anything she was flirting I tried to
give her a smooch she kind of like
rejected me she was kind of mean about
it right
um
or I took it as mean right okay and it
was fine she got out of the tax there
was no animosity between us it was just
you know it wasn't going to happen and
but then I something in my head like I
told the driver let's go get some
cocaine you know so next thing you know
me and this Taxi Driver are getting some
cocaine and
um
and then he at one point wants to get
some hookers you know the taxi driver
yeah I'm surprised he didn't think it
was a uh sting that you were asking to
get cocaine I feel like that's a lot of
drivers actually get pinched that way
yeah I think I I think maybe yeah I
guess he didn't give up you didn't seem
undercover yeah yeah I seem to overcover
probably
I think he's like damn somebody better
cover this you were covered yeah yeah
so anyway dude fast forward a couple
hours later I'm driving this guy's taxi
he's in the back and we're talking about
an LA Yellow Cab we're talking about a
New York I'm sorry New York New York
Yellow Cab okay great we're up in North
Harlem I'm driving this guy's taxi and
he's in the back with a hooker right did
he have the beaded seat thing how was
the seat comfort
on the seat the back seat was pretty
nice I remember the front seat once you
were driving
I thought it was pretty good I was
pretty scared I just wanted to get back
to my hotel sure sure and I didn't know
I just I would love to be up in that
cockpit for a second you know of a real
New York City Yellow Cab and just see
the setup because I never get my setup
right
it felt like thanks to phone cord to
just like I I never feel like I had my
console right yeah you're right I'd like
to see how they do it I think it never
it felt like somebody had sat in there
who had like
it felt like the guy in there was like
he was gonna leave his children probably
oh okay it had a sinking yeah yeah yeah
you could feel the despair also the guy
was in the back seat that's true so it
wasn't just yeah so in terms of his Vibe
you it had you had it coming from a
bunch of directions right and then
anyway so I ended up on and I had to do
Opie and Jim Norton that morning right
oh so I ended up on the radio and Daryl
strawberry was in there
and um I get to the radio station I
can't even talk right I'm just like
blasted out of my brain you know and I'm
still thinking I was still ducking off
in the bathroom I'm doing cocaine in the
bathroom or in the Stalls at serious
radio Andy Cohen's in there peeing in
the next one talking to me right and I'm
just sitting in there just blasting up
yeah yeah yeah and uh
and then what I wouldn't what I would I
would always kill for the single
occupant bathroom yeah with the key oh
when you got in there you're like God
it's your office what won't I blow this
line off yeah I got every surface
imaginable from counter
the saddest part was doing some cocaine
off the um baby changing station yeah I
got a joke about that in my new special
do you yeah right yeah
just for you thank you
um but yeah so that was a that was a
night for me when oh and I saw Daryl
strawberry he was on the radio station
right oh you saw Daryl while gacked up
he was the other guest
oh wow so that was a moment for me where
everything kind of lines could you tell
no hmm I don't think I had on sunglasses
which was weird I've been doing well
going on this show yeah and I had on
sunglasses and uh I could barely talk I
remember yeah and that was scary because
my only gift I had in my voice the only
thing in my life I'd had to express
myself was my voice yeah and suddenly I
couldn't use it okay and you had and
your mind which you now had to use
because you were going to be interviewed
on the radio yeah and it was real scary
and then also this moment of seeing
Daryl strawberry someone who I had
always thought was all coped out of his
brain sure because that's all I'd ever
heard right was the old stories I didn't
know that he was a sobra guy and had his
deal together oh yeah I assumed he had
his deal together but I did think he'd
be able to spot you still yeah I didn't
know what I thought I think okay which I
don't know if that even makes any sense
but there was some alignment at that
moment of like me not having control
over my voice me having a perceptionist
somebody else that was false or
something sure and that just lined up
and you hadn't slept and you were on
cocaine yeah
yeah
but it lined up for me that I needed
something whatever that like like like
the uh what's that thing you tighten
with the colors in it Kaleidoscope
whatever the Kaleidoscope is that it
makes people have to realize that
something is wrong yeah though that was
the moment where it was like oh that's
interesting I could see right down those
things never made me those like being in
Midtown Manhattan have a meeting have a
you know have a big like production
meeting on something
um and you could be able to get there
get there half hour late uh
uh desperate to have a cigarette so like
finding an abandoned office and smoking
out the window and being almost very
much in trouble and it being really
clear those moments were so about
surviving that that hour that they NE I
never thought about them with any deeper
perspective I never thought oh my God
what has my life become I was just like
I
it would be easier to take the train I'd
be faster to take the train home to my
cocaine but I can't do Coke on the train
so it was all just like figuring out the
video game of being a drug addict wow
took up it was just a Scramble for the
present problem and as soon as that
problem was solved I moved on I wasn't
like I can't believe you know I remember
I went
I went into a meeting holding a bottle
of Pedialyte because I was not eating
anything I was just drinking Pedialyte
doing cocaine
and I was I was with people I knew and
we were waiting for other people to join
the meeting that we didn't know and I
said if my nose bleeds or if I pass out
it's because I have a sinus infection
don't worry you know and I'll give a
signal if I think I'm about to pass out
and then
then and even to them I was like because
I'm sick right because that's why wow
yeah what's the signal too I can't
remember
um
something like I got you know Geronimo
um would be a great thing to say before
you pass out in your nose explodes with
blood yeah that covered it well
or timber timber yeah uncle
yeah yeah to do all of life to the gods
yeah
um wow so people just didn't know huh
well they reached a point where people
wondered
um were you getting too big in pot were
you getting too popular that people were
even afraid to question you and kind of
thing I don't think so right I don't
think so
um because like
I was been very lucky with
um I've been very lucky with having
an audience that's grown and grown but
you know
you gotta that that's a certain level
before no one will question you right I
don't even if they have that level on TV
sometimes but I wasn't like you know
right I wasn't uh
Steven Spielberg or something yeah
Michael Landon that wasn't some Michael
Landon who a bunch of Yes Men tell him
he doesn't need to show up to the State
Fair
oh
That Shook us man what do you have a lot
of people did you have a lot of people
around who knew about your problem I
have family members it's like addiction
is in my family so
there's
um
so I remember I would drive by the A8
there's an AAA room down the street from
where I stay in Los Angeles and I would
drive by there even through the parking
lot sometimes and one time a family
member of mine was like you know normal
people aren't driving through the
parking lot of AAA meetings to see
what's going on right so there was
something inside of me that wondered and
the biggest thing for me is a mo is like
it like make trying to keep my emotions
sober like I wasn't insane like I
definitely partied some
I don't drink because I'm afraid if I
have a beer I'm gonna go get cocaine
I've never had a drinking problem yeah
I'm gonna take one Sip and then it just
gives me an excuse to get Coke right but
mine was just always like thinking
something was wrong with me I always
felt like
I've always felt like something like
there's a to-do list that I never even
wrote yeah that I'm responsible to do
and the pain the energy the
responsibility of it is always every day
when I wake up I'm like I gotta go I
just have to do so I always have to do
so it's just I have to prove I'm trying
to prove myself to nothing yeah I don't
even know what it is so that was
something in my life that made it tough
um that just exhausted me you know so a
lot of my stuff came from that kind of
thing like um just feeling inferior
trying to always make like I'd I'd fall
in love with a girl and then the second
I if I got a date with her the second I
did there was some other girl it was
like just I always needed more I always
needed something else there was always a
missing piece to me being okay yeah and
there was no there was I could there was
never a piece I could find that was
gonna make it that would fit there's no
piece out there it was just there was
something wrong with my program in a
little bit how did you feel at that time
did you feel like
other [__] needs to other people and
other things need to fall into place so
I'm happy or did you feel like it was on
you
you know people who blame the outside
world yeah they go yeah my problem is
that people come into my life and create
stressful situations or that thing of
like if you meet one [__] one day you
met an [__] if you meet an [__]
every day you're the [__]
um I think that happened kind of later
the like but early on it was just I'm
not doing well enough I'm not doing
enough to be okay for myself
was what it turned into
um doing enough like in your career in
anything something yeah and it was
always this invisible thing like
nothing was ever I couldn't manage well
enough to make things okay even if I was
managing great you know
um and I couldn't enjoy I was never I
was never enjoying myself I was always
caught up how can things be different or
better or
you know uh
so a lot of that stuff for me a lot of
like
not even knowing who I was like I need
to needing you to let me know who I was
if I was okay yeah for sure all that
kind of stuff so the drugs was just I
think uh
I like drugs because I like cocaine
because it I could feel how I wanted to
immediately yeah of course like liquor
and beer and stuff it's like
that was just a bunch of damn
just yeah it's it postpones [__] yes I
wanted the Express Train I wanted to
feel I wanted to feel right now oh my
God yeah
but then I would get I would get I would
end up by myself looking at pornography
you know just geeked out looking at
hookers just it always devolved into
some weird space for me too and well and
you're chasing some
you're chasing I mean people say you're
chasing the first time you did cocaine I
don't think that's true you're just
chasing the
yeah you're chasing the first line that
night
oh yeah and if I think about doing
cocaine say if I think about it right
I think some of them at a party right
there's somebody you open a cabinet
there's some tits in there for some
reason right it's a party you know
and somebody has some cocaine if I do
some in this hypothetical situation yeah
the next thing I think about doing is
another line of cocaine oh of course I
don't think about enjoying the party I
don't think about if you know uh when I
think about getting a bat I mean I just
go okay well all right now we need a bag
of this and fewer people that know about
it the better yeah yeah yeah now that
was a fun thing too is the secret
Espionage side of it it was almost like
you were oh my God yeah you were like
the the bad guy that everybody was
looking for you talk about the
Craigslist thing I mean there was a guy
I don't know a guy it was a Craigslist
ad that someone was selling Adderall in
L.A the ad was written like home from
finals and have all this leftover
Adderall and I remember thinking
remember thinking how can I pull up
and I was like how will I know if it's a
sting and also I kept thinking like this
is a pretty low stakes thing for the LA
County Sheriff's Office to be behind
yeah like to wanna meet in a
recreational park to sell someone 10
Adderall it's a lot of Manpower yeah on
a pretty small movement
um
and then I thought will it help or hurt
that I'm a little famous
like when I pull up will it be more like
could I yeah will I be more noticeable
or
um will that become a distracting thing
right like officers I'm just you know
of course it's not me
I don't know man you paint so many great
scenes I was so late all It's the
funniest thing was I was so late to meet
drug dealers because I was a cocainext
everything was always running and I had
a dealer in La who was Fury I mean she
was so angry about the time she was
always like we don't do should we she
had some operation with her sons we
don't do this we don't do this yeah it's
like a family recipe it was just like
this is a half hour late I was like you
got you're you gotta understand your
clientele like we're nothing we're not
waking up ready for our errands we're
not waking up yeah yeah we've been up
we've been up there's
I'm you have to go to a bunch of
different ATMs you know that this is a
this is a process yeah I'm on a
Pedialyte hotline right now I'm chugging
Pedialyte and if I yell Geronimo it
means I'm about to pass out you gotta
cut me some slack also LA traffic is a
real thing I thought taking Wilton would
save time
I had a dealer once who preferred to
deal in front of police
who preferred to deal in front of police
stations on the theory that if he got
jumped he would rather be close to
police oh yeah yeah that makes sense I
guess so wasn't the most fun it's scary
yeah it wasn't a great meet up but yeah
oh the scariest like I remember like
this guy would always bring his husky
with him right so okay the Husky would
come up to the car first right and kind
of he's like you know the drill pause
that like just up to the window yeah and
you like you know the drill Willis is
gonna Circle the car or whatever the
Huskies named Willis right so I'd be
sitting in there and I was what's that
drill what's the what's the Husky doing
the Husky would kind of come up and just
go around the car you had to keep the
windows down to make sure there were one
of the people in the car I think just to
you know I think he you know the first
time he brought the dog in just in the
sat in the back of the vehicle okay so
the dog would get to know your smell
right so I think now the dog had like a
semblance of you know who was who right
okay
so Willis would come up and he starts
smelling but I would get I was so just
gacked up I was just paranoid right and
then one time he gets in man and he just
starts crying the dog
um
foreign
the guy I don't know if I'd have been
able to know maybe I could have noticed
if the dog was crying but I don't know
if I could have but the man got in and
wept and he started crying yeah and he
said his mama just died oh my God
and I
did it slow down the transaction
I needed to get that coat yeah
so it was like I remember in my head
being like for 60 seconds you have to
talk about his mom or make sounds that
are
sad sad sounds so where's Willis at this
point Willis sit in the back okay so
between you two
yeah kind of like we're sitting there we
assumed uh dog's eyes moving back and
forth yeah
yeah and I just remembered this like
making just like kind of sad like God
that's awful just like oh that's awful
God oh I never I remember one of the
sounds was like
it was like oh like it was almost a
little not sad it was like oh that's the
worst sound because now you just you
went through your your sfx bank and you
just hit a weird one yeah A through Z of
sad yeah yeah
[Music]
to you know just like but I remember I
got to one I was like oh because I'm
just thinking I'm ahead 60 seconds sad
sounds 60 seconds of sad sounds get to
the code get to the coke yeah and the
dude is crying man it's just so moments
like that where you just like what is
going on I don't know how to handle this
well I will say there's a lot of factors
in that story and and
[Music]
yes you know you could have had more
empathy in the moment but
he's also a drug dealer who brings a
husky into your car and Willis is
sitting in the back seat so it's an odd
situation yeah it's not like anyone else
would have handled it a lot better
yeah I always took odd situations like
that like it was totally normal I think
and I still have yeah 100 nothing about
that nothing about those things I
remember thinking like God the day is
how do people get through their day with
all these meetups they have to do yeah
cocaine dealers you mean yeah just or
like you know yeah buying pills and I
was like man I was like what I can
barely I got a call but I'm supposed to
meet this person before I'm not gonna
you know how many business calls I did
on mute you know like on a street corner
being like dang you said six you said
six you said six yeah okay cool yeah
yeah yeah no I mean we love no like we
love the script you said six I was like
it was a real uh
it was exhausting it was exhausting yeah
but it kept you in the moment I'll say
that I had reflexes like an alley cat
yeah you know like yeah could grab this
it was like uh people meditate to be in
the moment you know like when people do
like mindfulness meditation it's to be
fully present and like when I was trying
to get drugs I was full I was like okay
bird siren off in the distance bicycle
that's the second time that like every
single thing we're here yeah yeah it did
put you right there right there there
was some immediacy God damn it maybe
there was something about that that I
really liked about it
that it puts you right like
because now I will say this I've thought
a lot about the moment right like the
moment doesn't exist as much as it used
to the moment it used to be if something
happened it wasn't recorded all the time
it wasn't captured on a phone if you had
a good story you had to get to your
friends and tell it yeah and if somebody
else had a good story you had to get
them to the party that he dude listen to
what happened to Ron right yeah and that
was the only way in the moment was like
it wasn't able to be captured right okay
so it had so much value whereas now all
moments are captured right so it's like
there is not as much value to them in a
way because they're
yeah well do you think that's the
capturing of it like you mean you can
get a photo or a video of it or do you
think that as we get older we just had
so many moments they become
I don't know they just become a little
less it's a good point like time like
time people say that about time that's a
great that's a really good point like
time when you're young everything takes
so long but when you're older it takes
it goes faster because you've done it so
many times yeah like the most I mean we
both get to do really exciting things
but we've done versions of them before
and you go oh this is this is yeah okay
this is how I thought this is what I
thought it might be like okay yeah it's
the same feeling as
you know the moment yeah I think uh I
never take stock in the moment really
I never do I I just like
I've never seen like playing the world's
greatest venue or I never I mean you
know I later I I can appreciate those
things but I never have uh I remember I
was down uh in the bottom of Patagonia
in Chile and it was like all glaciers
three hours from Antarctica I was just
staring at the sun setting over all
these glaciers and I was saying to
myself like try to enjoy this try to
enjoy this try to enjoy this adjust
just uh later I appreciated it but I'm
never really oh my god do you think that
the world is boring to you and this
isn't a judgment of you this is like
like sometimes as uh
I think as somebody who has been in and
out of recovery and stuff like that I've
noticed at times that I looked at the
world in ways the world always felt a
little bit boring to me
um I used to have that yeah I I did
um
yeah what do you think or that boring or
that boring
not that the world was always boring
excuse me but that boring was the
absolute worst state
to be in boredom was intolerable
yeah
and it's tough if you have a creative
mind because a creative mind can get
kind of bored kind of easy because it
can think of different things
yeah so it has more toys to play with
you know I also have a thing so it's
less like you were saying you had kind
of the grass is greener Envy for you
always wanted more of some other
scenario I also
like I reached a point where I felt
um
I felt very satisfied I remember I was
doing this tour in 2017
and I was on stage at a theater in St
Louis
and it was sold out and it was a Tuesday
you know it wasn't like and I remember
when I first went to the Comedy Cellar
rock or one of these guys being like
anyone can sell out on the weekend wait
till you sell out on a Wednesday or a
Tuesday so I'm on stage and it felt like
the end of the movie comedian you know
the documentary Seinfeld which when I
saw that I was like that's what I want I
want to stand in a theater and do
stand-up like that's what I want and
then I was doing it and I thought it
wasn't a bad feeling
but the feeling was okay
this is it this is all this is kind of
as big as I pictured
like and I'm doing it and that's great
right but I had a slight feeling of
I don't know
okay I don't know what's next
like I was a bit
um
I started I started to freak out because
I was kind of sad I was a little
satisfied yeah but I but I don't want to
I don't want to make it seem like it was
a good feeling it was an odd feeling
yeah or sort of this is it this is what
I wanted and it's pretty cool right but
having a goal really kept me uh
occupied and I wasn't sure if I had
another one wow dude that sounds like a
great entry to like a mer like a
detective scenario having a goal really
kept me off yeah having a goal kept me
moving and I and I had reached the other
one yeah it seemed like I mean it was a
very very lucky golden I got a p man
yeah I'm gonna pee real fast okay cool
you all right 100 right
um when you think about like you're so I
think that these days there's kind of
like two can I ask you something else
about addiction go ahead please okay
I think there's like two types of
addiction that I notice I notice people
that are like
alcoholics right like they have what is
in like the the big book of alcoholism
you know what I'm talking about yeah yes
they have the disease of alcoholism then
I also notice there's this other group
who have opioid addiction right yeah
yeah yeah and it's no I'm not saying
that some of them couldn't also have
alcoholism no but there's something
about the I mean there's something so
Insidious about opioids and how they get
in people's wiring yeah that you're not
I don't want to get into the whole like
willpower and disease and I know that a
lot of people have a lot of feelings
about that all of them valid
but you're not choosing to take that
opioid like that that is some science
fiction level [__] the way it gets into
people's
uh
you know limbic system and like you
cannot stop taking them you are in agony
and is that and that just seems like
that just seems like some other
uh
there should be a different word for it
other than addiction because I think
most people associate addiction
most people would say like it's not a
choice but you guys are choosing it a
little bit and there's I don't know it's
a I I really do respect everyone's
thoughts on that because it's a tricky
[__] thing but with the opioid
compulsion to take the opioid or the
dependence the opioid dependence I guess
that that does feel like something else
sometimes
yeah it's almost like they made a cheat
code for your DNA yeah it'd be like if
you
you know if you like
handed someone someone who doesn't like
cocaine and you handed them a flower
every day with cocaine in it and they
smelled it eventually want more cocaine
you're yeah it feels like you're getting
into the wiring of people who
we're just looking for pain management
right right and we're not looking to
feel um
you know some sort of
psychological physical we're not we're
not trying to feel some drugged out
feeling right
yeah we're not trying to change their
state of consciousness I guess yeah it's
almost like they just they took into a
new lab and like we're going to find
some way to Trump the the system yeah I
mean drugs are already overriding
your desire to survive in a lot of cases
and opioids it seems like 10 times more
so yeah
yeah that's one thing it's just
unbelievable to me it's like and how our
country lets that kind of happen like
how our Drug Administration like that
did you see dope sick I did yeah it was
excellent it broke my heart yeah
you know it just like
you'd think there's a I think it used to
feel like when Reagan was in right back
when Reagan yeah that they're never
never did a thing wrong right but or
just whoever it used to feel like at a
time in in in life right and this could
be me romanticizing life that there was
a time when your government or some
overall governing bodies like
they looked out for the humans for the
people in the country right maybe maybe
that's a just a crazy View
but he used to know I don't mean I I I
didn't make it you feel like crazy but
yeah I guess and maybe that was just me
being a kid and the Pledge of Allegiance
it could have you know yeah I think
there's a but then now it seems like
you do not can you cannot count on your
country to look out for you or you're
the administrations within your country
I'd say that that's what I got out of
dope sick kind of it was like they
trumped the because they hired people
from the Food and Drug Administration
and then work on their own board
and they kind of like
they made it so they would keep getting
these pills like past like able to be
used yeah well it's the basic problem
that with
um
with harmful habits I know that sounds
like a corny way to say it but with
things we
do to ourselves we have a morality play
about it you know like
um
oh yeah they took they took opioids for
post-surgery and then they couldn't and
then they they couldn't stop and they
started lying to their doctor and it all
it very quickly becomes
um
something got set in motion but you the
user of the chemical you're kind of the
problem you know you're you don't have
strong willpower you would rather be
high on an opioid I mean and and there's
again like
it's a strange thing here's how I sort
of feel like is are are drug addicts
making a choice when they use drugs this
is a crisis we set in motion but I don't
think we're in control of it at all at a
point I mean this is because it's a
crisis whose timing you can't control
like the the immediacy of drug addiction
you can't predict you have no power over
once it starts right
um no it's it's that we see it as a
story of uh
a bad thing you did you know like
I think some people look at Tiger Woods
and they go his pill use is kind of
because he had a tragic character flaw
earlier in his life as opposed to maybe
the guy that has to perform at that
level physically might develop a
dependence on pills
I do think people like to read into
the dependence on drugs some sort of
like deeper moral problem you have
and it might be because when you are on
drugs you make seriously a moral
decisions sometimes so I don't know
so I don't think the country's
ever looked out for I think a lot of I
mean
I don't judge people for having a harsh
view of
addicts a lot of people have addicts in
their lives and you can't just go it's a
disease and I you know like it it can
really
um
it's very painful to other people yeah
oh yeah I mean it's a mess they're a
mess yeah life's so hard already life's
like
life's like a table piled high with so
much [__] like a bad you know when you
go to like a little restaurant in a tiny
circular ass table and they don't have
room for anything oh yeah table pile
type of [__] and drugs come in and drugs
you think are going to solve all your
problems and they kick the legs out from
under it yeah they're just a mess
it's it's
they're a disaster
do you what do you think I know people
use them and they don't feel it no and
some people are talking just for myself
right they're a disaster oh yeah I
remember I got back from that trip of
doing the taxi driver ended up dropping
me off he uh after you did opium yeah
right so then I had to go to the hotel
go to the airport after
oh I ended up I get to the only way to
the airport I'm still texting the taxi
driver yeah seeing if he can get us some
coat like I'm leaving
there's no oh yeah yeah I'm texting the
guy I've been up all night with and then
when I get home I had left some cocaine
on my counter I finally get off the
plane as a miserable flight you're just
kind of rattling the whole way yeah you
get there I walk in my apartment there's
still some cocaine on the counter and I
did it of course and I was like I gotta
get some help
okay
I would never
for one it was my part of my career I'd
worked so hard for and then I'm having
good opportunities like Opie and Jim was
an amazing opportunity to be on there
and I was letting drug like drugs were
there it was just like and if you'd
asked me the day before would you ever
go to Opie and gym high on cocaine I'd
be like you are out of your mind yeah
and so there I was you know so I was
like wow I have no control over this
um and then it becomes who the hell
scheduled Opie and Jim when I'm in the
middle of my cocaine are people nuts
you want me to go to Midtown Manhattan
to the serious satellite radio building
and record this
when you were grown up were you a hard
kid for your parents to kind of deal
with or do you think that they no I
tried to keep my personal life very
separate from my family I I really I
like I know were you really I didn't
want to bring trouble home because
that's everyone I I looked at people who
would get in trouble a lot and it's like
they'd leave their cigarettes out they'd
you know
they'd
they they get they'd tag up their own
garage like whatever right right I was
just like leave that [__] outside
um so you were good at hiding things I
was like uh
I was like a Michael Clayton
of bad kids I was like I kind of I was
like a fixer I was like all right here's
what we're gonna do he's the fixer yeah
have you seen that movie with George
Clooney he's a lawyer who kind of like
I mean I guess he doesn't fix the major
problems in the movie so
but he's affected yeah he just is a like
you know we're gonna get there it is the
truth can be adjusted yeah there you go
that's the that should be the because I
had a line for stand-up comedy
um all of a lot of these sound like the
titles for specials that you would have
I feel like yeah the truth can be
adjusted John Mulaney
um
but yeah do you feel like it was any
part of your like childhood that like
that you see that like part of your
addiction like or do you not is there
not a big connection there yeah there's
I mean
um
no not at all I do what I do and I don't
let it interfere with business AKA in
that case School
and I don't let it interfere with my
business meaning you know eighth grade
freshman year of high school
and I don't bring that [__] home you
know I don't
um
I don't smoke pot in my parents house
whatever it was I I took great pride in
in having a hard separation between my
life and my family like real Mafia Like
rules like we don't talk I don't bring
that home to my family yeah
that's pretty amazing yeah and because
it made my life easier not to yeah I
mean I almost got kidnapped twice and I
didn't tell my parents because I thought
it was gonna gum up dinner yeah I just
thought it was like I need to be able to
move free around the city I'm eight
years old okay I got [__] to do and if
they think you know it's dangerous this
is gonna slow me down yeah yeah that's
kind of the voice that comes out
sometimes in your material you'll be
telling a story about being eight years
old you're like but I need to be able to
move free about the city right I don't
have time for this yeah this is the game
I'm in this is the game I'm in yeah
these are the decisions I've made yeah
yeah these are the choices we've made
um were you a happy kid yeah I think I
was just kind of a loner I I didn't
really trust the world so I got into my
own space pretty early what were your
hobbies I like to collect stuff and hide
it under my I had three shelving unit in
my in my closet I like to hide weapons
under my bed yeah for home invasions oh
yeah crowbar
um hammers wow yeah ready to rock I I
was on the third floor of our house I
figured I'd hear
I thought no one in my family was ready
that's what I thought I saw Cape Fear
the Robert De Niro one oh my dad's a
lawyer like Nick Nolte in that movie and
I was like oh my God Nick knowledge gets
his ass kicked like my dad would get his
ass kicked by Robert De Niro yeah long
hair Robert De Niro would beat the [__]
out of my dad so I started putting
Weapons Under My Bed and I was just
ready to go and my whole plan was the
the circuits for the house were also on
the third floor so I was going to shut
all the power off nice and now they're
on my turf hmm
now I'm in charge
dang yeah and I'm 10 and I got a crowbar
but you're planning it's interesting to
have almost so so many of your own like
plans it was stressful though oh yeah my
parents wouldn't set the alarm I was
just like you are fools this is a
dangerous world yeah and I'm the only
one ready to rock I am locked and loaded
bro I would I was so scared like our
neighborhood like people are like dogs
are always giving birth and people were
always like they would always catch men
like kind of gaying around like like
married men like in abandoned pools and
[__] in the neighborhood and people are
always doing pills and
you know and getting you know filing
lawsuits down at the fairground because
you go to the fairgrounds like a day
early down there for 50 cents you could
ride any ride why were people filing
lawsuits because they go do that and
then they try to you know they ever you
know half the people that show up or
like laying outside of the room oh I got
you okay yeah yeah yeah you know it's
just that kind of [__] like did you feel
unsafe as a kid oh yeah okay yeah people
would drive by our house and like throw
rocks through the windows and yell the
n-word and stuff and it's like we're not
even you know it's just like that could
be very confusing to us yeah I was like
well I don't even know yeah what's
happening you know it was just a scary
place right and so I remember at night I
would like I wet the bed every night
sure I'd went to bed two or three times
at night and so
I'd get up some nights and have to clean
the sheets and lay them back down and
then if I did a third time I wouldn't
even have any sheets what a lonely
activity that is oh it was a little kid
in the middle of the night just when
you're washing your own sheets
just waiting by the dryer I mean like
all right yeah
up all night no one's maybe your parents
know but just smoking invisible
cigarettes even yeah just like
okay I'll switch them what a lonely what
a lonely little errand kids have to do
dude that probably was one of the
loneliest moments of my probably I would
say in my childhood not and not to try
to get into self-pity but it's like that
was something it would be like man I
hate
that I do this because I'm scared I feel
like something's wrong with me and then
I always have to do this by myself you
know because it would take you know it
would take a good 20 minutes if you
clean your bed up and then put on some
other sheets and then
you know um
even if you didn't have to go wash them
you know if you had to wash them the
next day or something but just to make
it all clean you know get out the car
the cleanser and clean the clean the
stuff but I remember I would look in my
closet I would tie tie a string from one
door knob to the other like I would make
I'd have to look outside of the windows
and look in every corner just making
sure why would you tie one a string from
one door knob to the other and then I
put a couple of J Bales on a couple
Jingle Bells on it okay and then you
would hear them if somebody went one way
or the other if someone was coming into
your room yeah okay so there was just
like a ton of like a lot of fear I had a
ton of fear when I was a kid yeah
and then I guess when you're in fear you
kind of like
fear is kind of a lonely place to be oh
it's very lonely yeah so you're always
kind of ice you're you're the one who's
looking out yeah so I think maybe a lot
of that kind of shaped how I was when I
was young you know it's probably what
hell is
being very very afraid that's a good
interesting call
yeah there's nothing worse than being
really afraid really ashamed and Afraid
is rough oh a shame too if you put that
in there like well if you add to it like
I'm In This Disaster and I'm to blame
for it yeah
yeah
did you have any issues as you got more
popular with your own ego
probably but
uh
but because I've noticed those in my own
life you know it's not a judgment I'm
just curious no no no and I'm not I'm
not trying when I say but I'm not trying
to dial it back
um
yeah I mean
uh ego's kind of a scary thing right
because you don't really know where it
is yeah I don't know where it is and you
don't know what doses are healthy you
know how some people have like good
boundaries yeah and they're like no I
don't allow this and you go like that
sounds like sometimes there's a side of
me that thinks that boundaries sound
stuck up
uh like that doesn't work for me I don't
allow a hundred people to crash on my
floor out of nowhere you know and I'm
like
I always uh that didn't really make
sense my example
um no like I I uh
let me think about that
I feel like I'm rambling right now it's
my ego
for sure like
like did you feel like once you achieved
like some level of success like do you
think success was your driving force
like what do you think kind of with some
of your driving force to do stand up and
to to entertain like where do you think
that kind of comes from for you is it a
necessity is it a desire to be seen as a
creative is it what do you think do you
have any thoughts on it I have many I'm
trying to
um let me trying to think of a
semi-interesting answer
yeah I wanted to I wanted people to say
that guy's the best at what he does
wow me even if it's 10 people right I
wanted I wanted some people to go that
is he's the best of what he did my dad's
a very successful guy and very
um
very smart
very
he just he he had stature to me it still
does I mean but he has stature he just
people would tell me growing up your
dad's the smartest person I've ever met
your dad's the best attorney I've ever
seen like wow he just
I wanted stature from a young age I
think
well that makes sense now which is a
strange thing because what does that
mean that means you've already
accomplished things
past tense or
and also it's not great for a comedian
you know you don't I don't like when I
don't want to be a comedian where it's
like everyone respects me but I'm not
funny anymore yeah I don't think you
could ever be that that's nice of you to
say but we all we're all running from
that oh that's a good next bet yeah well
it's interesting you say about stature
because you almost have this
thing sometimes and I don't know if or
maybe I'm trying to see into this a
little where it's like can't you like
you almost operate in a way that and you
said it yourself like I've I've done
this like it's already completed like a
little bit guys I'm already the number
one entertainment in America can we just
sit back and please enjoy it right yeah
even though we even though you couldn't
even enjoy the moments you know it's
like even though it's like but that's
almost like what I would perceive like
stature to a kid it's like
it's already been done you know like
it's already yeah it's like the first
concert I went to was when I was 11 I
went to see Frank Sinatra for my
birthday of course you did yeah and what
else would you take YouTube
and I I asked my dad for tickets I I or
I told my dad you know Frank Sinatra's
coming to town and he was like what uh
you know he's a busy guy he hadn't
totally been checking in with me in a
couple years he's like Jesus all right
so then we went to see Sinatra at a
casino in Aurora Illinois
and uh
yeah that's what I wanted
to come out and be and everyone just go
like this guy's the best wow yeah
there's no question
you know when you walked out I I don't
know if I've ever I've been jealous a
couple times when you walked out in your
radio City special the way that thing
looked I was like man
oh well that's all Alex Timbers our
director and but I said that guy looks
like a real guy that's what I thought to
myself thank you that was the that was
the intended that was the desired effect
that guy looks like a real guy yeah I'm
very envious when I come into like when
I when I've run into you
um like I don't I don't I feel very out
of place in like La a lot like I feel
like you guys I feel like I have this
thing of like I'm scared to go to the
store I'm scared to go to The Improv you
guys kill in a different way that I
can't do hmm
I feel like I get
I think there was a time when there was
certainly like kind of like a
it was like
there was the same guys kind of at the
store a lot you know no you specifically
you because you're you seem like you're
having fun on stage oh thank you you're
extremely funny
thank you you seem like I wish I could
be as
I wish I could
I feel like you're able to access a
different level of
um understanding of Comedy that I don't
and I I when I see you perform or I
watch you I I have a lot of
I have a lot of envy that this man is
this man is very good that's nice of you
to say that's
that's that stature I was looking for
yeah it's a 10 foot tall Ronald Reagan
this is a 10 foot tall Ronald Reagan
that Reagan won't even visit yeah yeah
yeah
um
I feel like you can go
any I feel like especially these days
The Comedy Store is very much like I
don't know if they're even it's not even
that there's not that many people
performing over there that are
Headliners really you know
yeah I guess and that's not the term
there's not as many uh there's a lot of
news I think like I was doing the
bourbon room last night and I was
backstage and
I have this thought a lot where I'm like
who I'm just like I wish I was funny
like I wish I was funny like
like I'm gonna get out there and I'm
gonna do my thing and it's just like I
[__] wish
I wish I was like like watching your
special I'm like oh I was like that I
wish I was fun
oh that's sweet of you
yeah I wish I like like you're working
on two levels at once
you're working you're working on two
levels
where you know
you both know and you don't know what
you're doing yeah
you know exactly what you're doing
the only other person who can do it is
like Tracy I feel like you like you
operate at one level that's extremely
silly and funny but you're you're aware
of that but what you present to us is
that you're not aware of what you're
saying yeah
yeah and I don't know if I am sometimes
either that's the tough I think you are
but it's but but it's but I don't know
and that's what's really that's what's
very captivating about it oh thanks man
I mean you I remember when Nate bargatsu
was on your podcast you said that you
were waiting until you got a little
older to watch Malcolm in the Middle
yeah and I think about like
I think about that a lot you know thanks
man just what exactly that means
yeah I think some things I'm just saving
you know what I felt like most of my
life but I felt like a late bloomer man
I felt like only in the past few years
when I got into like trying to get into
recovery and stuff have I started to
even grow up
oh yeah I felt like I put a lot of like
I didn't I've put a lot of my evolving
off and a lot of me's never wanted to
grow up because
I still want to get
the things I deserved as a child
from my environment from my parents and
I think there's a part of me that like I
mean I can feel it when I even say that
I can [__] feel something inside of
me grip this literally grip the [__]
skin inside of me yeah like don't make
me grow up
without
being able to have had some of these
things
uh there's a feeling you needed to have
as a kid that you didn't have yeah and
you don't want to close the door on that
until you
can give yourself that yeah and I think
it makes it real
uh it almost makes me hate growing up
because
I'm never gonna be able to get back
there you know I know that sounds kind
of crazy but
um
like I'll never be able to get back to
those moments where
like my parents should have been in a
certain way or things should have been
safe or
I don't know uh
but man I it
it hurts me yeah you know and some
people say it's like you got to get over
those things and you have to go through
your step work and you have to let go of
resentments and and I believe that right
but
there's something inside of me that's
even although I do those things that
still is having a very tough time
letting go
you know and growing up it's tough man
that that part for me has been tough and
I know some people may sound that sounds
like a baby or whatever
uh that's okay I can't
I can't deny what I feel you know or
what I know it's not even a feeling
what's wrong with a baby they're pretty
interesting right that's a good point
actually yeah
the the world wasn't that you had some
times in the world wasn't that kind to
you when you were a kid yeah I didn't
trust it right out of the gate yeah you
know and uh sometimes I don't know why
my mother had a really tough time like
um knowing if there was something wrong
with you she couldn't she had like
almost an emotional autism I use that
term a lot but and my father was real
old so I think I was always scared he
was gonna die you know sure and uh so it
made it just I don't know the recipe was
really weird man
so anyway I talk about that stuff a lot
I'm not trying to harp on it but there's
sometimes you just have to wait for
yourself to get there you know it's like
you can do a lot of the work on the
outside
but sometimes it's like that inner child
or whatever they say like that
[__] can be a little slow you
know
yeah
and might always and and he might always
be like that yeah
I mean you got a lot
you got a lot out of being that kid too
like your Independence the confidence
you have like you had to adapt
in a different way and a lot of that has
helped you a lot yeah
I'm not saying that makes up for it I'm
just saying sometimes I wonder myself I
go I think I'll be like this all Always
Forever yeah I think this might be it
and maybe that's all right you know I
love the way you're able to have this
you have this very like uh
looking at the presentation of yourself
and like almost like it's a judge at a
at a school fair you know like this is
like the judge at a Michael Landon
drawing contest
who's gonna get the treat well guess
what no picture's gonna be perfect
because there's a bunch of [__]
little kids drawing Michael Landon yeah
so not one of them is going to be
perfect but the effort
and the joy of watching a bunch of
little kids draw Michael Landon for
their mother hoping to win Candy
is the is life yeah
do I have the best drawing
uh yeah I don't know but it's just the
fact that everybody's doing it is a good
time I guess yeah I mean dude nothing
sounds more fun than a family having a
Michael Landon drawing contest oh man we
were keyed up
we were excited
[Music]
um
trying to think of what else we can talk
about
you know oh yeah sorry and we'll start
I'll no I don't I'll put that in the
beginning yeah what do you think about
new specials as you get as you get older
yeah and as we get further away from the
the part of us that was the first
special yes
yeah let's just call it let's call the
exciting part of us the first special
yeah do you like has it been tough to
evolve as a person and as a comedian has
there been scary moments where you're
like I don't know if I want to evolve
like who do I evolve into that's
something I think about sometimes yeah I
was more uh
you know this special I've got coming
out
um
is kind of
it isn't kind of it is about everything
from Intervention through rehab and
after uh so at the moment or in the past
two years
I haven't wondered what I'm gonna talk
about on stage but now having shot this
thing in you know and
I'm really really happy with it
and it's longer than my other specials
and it it I'm thrilled that it's longer
it's kind of this was the time to do
this chunk of material this was the
moment in my life to do this with that
gone now I start to wonder hmm yeah
now I'm now I don't remember how to do
comedy and oh that's a great statement
oh yeah I don't last night I was like I
don't have jokes I don't
uh maybe I'll try this old one that was
part of the hour that I cut
but I just I don't what is going on here
how do I do this I don't know what I'm
doing wow
yeah that's scary it's really scary
letting something go putting out
something that's new putting out
something that's more like
obviously we tell stories that are based
on our real lives or have moments some
of them you know yeah but to put out
something that's like really this is
like me just tracking part of my life
and it was a little bit like
I can't I can't do
I can't talk about other things until I
get this out I don't mean like people
were waiting for it I just mean I don't
this
I this has to be what the next special
is
and it was rather easy because there
were lots of stories from it
um
wasn't easy to
to get it where it was but you know it
took two years of touring but it uh it
felt like
okay inevitably
there's you know over an hour of
nonsense that happened yeah so
do you is it interesting like because
some people I think as we get older they
want us
to be older in a way or they want we
have to evolve or something right
because for sure you know we can't have
the same thoughts and stuff that we had
when we were 10 years ago or 15 years
ago when we were starting
well I don't know is that is anyone
saying that no one is I mean that might
that's a good I mean wanting to evolve
is a good thing it's scary though I
think we're always arguing with some
straw man that's not really there of
what like what we should be talking I
mean I don't think that's a good point I
was just doing that yeah and now it's
trying to bring you into it no I did
that last night yeah right
I was like oh maybe I should be like
maybe I should have a lot of political
jokes I thought this standing back I was
about to go on well you're respected
enough man and it's such an interest
you're so yourself that if you just get
up on stage I am curious as to what is
John thinking about no way that's nice
you to say but like I went and saw stavi
at the Pittsburgh improv Stavros Hawk
yes yeah yeah and that I was like God I
was like that's a person who's just
funny right away that's a person who's
funny where I'm like
I'm willing like I'm just gonna watch
him talk to the crowd I'm gonna watch
any I I would kill to have that wow
that's it I well I guess everybody wants
a little bit of something else you know
or would love to have moments of the
other person you know oh yeah
oh yeah that's like avi's wild he says
[__] a lot too and I don't say it that
much he does yeah yeah he does he likes
saying I feel like he's almost does it
deliberately you think I think he I
think he knows exactly what he's doing
yeah you might as for it right away or
Brody like yeah like that Brody is very
interesting the Brody was it's almost a
reverse psychology I don't even know
what he was doing half the time up there
I mean
Brody like
oh I oh I mean
the amount of times I went why can't I
here I am it's my own show I'm in a
theater I'm in an arena like if I could
bring the same excitement that Brody
brought to warming up
uh a Chelsea Handler audience I'd be I'd
have it made why can't I have that thing
you know
but do you did someone at some point in
your life or did some straw man tell you
that you don't because like when I watch
your special last night I was watching
the um
yeah I mean some somebody always tells
me I'm boring some some voices though
you're boring and no no one wants to
hear this and you're not fun and you're
not you're actually not you're not good
at performing your own material that's
something dude when I watched that I was
like man
um and I'd seen it before but I was like
I'm just so involved even when you go to
get the sip of water and drink it out of
the cup and you probably think man it
was a last minute decision no stool so
the water's got to go somewhere yeah it
was really interesting I was like that
he put it there that's what he's doing
but you probably thinking behind a light
bulb well you're going to get it yeah oh
yeah I was so bored right now no in that
moment I was like can I pick up a glass
of water without dropping it in front of
6 000 people because I was like I've
never had it on the floor before so no I
mean listen I also I I don't mean to
sound like oh I feel like [__] about my
well we always like we always just want
to be something yeah oh it's funny I
think there's no doubt there's probably
there's probably 20 guys when I watch
them like oh man I wish I had some of
that you know oh my God yeah that'd be
really cool absolutely and you know what
I don't think there's anything wrong
with I think it's a totally healthy
thing I think we've been talking a lot
about also yeah the things in us that we
feel are missing but
it's quite it's a good thing to watch
Stavros and be envious yeah like that's
that's something that gets me
or comedians who write jokes that I'm
like you know
when I hear well I just saw Nate's
special I was like God I wish I had
those yeah that's exciting I don't
there's nothing to me unhealthy about
that yeah that's true it's nice I think
and it's really just an admiration to
that person but I think that there's so
many people that for sure that look at
you and and think that way like I wish I
could be as put together as that guy you
know that's
and use the word haberdasher I saw in
one of them that was good yeah yeah yeah
um uh Harry Truman ran a haberdashery
that went bust Diddy that's the first
time I think I heard that word yeah
little kid hearing about Harry Truman
some guy opened one up I think by us
when we're growing up and
people thought it was like a hash Den or
whatever and they shut it down I
remember oh wow yeah
but
um in this violent place you were
growing up someone tried to open a
haberdashery yeah very nice they had a
lot of narcs bus a lot of people were
always doing narkin you know oh yeah
where they get some kid [__] you know
there's a thing called Snap what's it
called snaps it was this weird program
in Chicago where
Chicago PD would send
um like two 13 year olds up to a bar to
try to get in and then they'd bust the
bar
I knew I knew this one kid whose dad was
a detective and they so they sent him
and he went up and he went don't let me
in I'm here with snaps
I mean if that was true I I
in retrospect I I can't imagine that
would be like an actual CPD program
I like that I like that he didn't want
the bar to get busted yeah yeah and then
he could probably come back the next
weekend and be like I did you a solid
yeah let me in yeah then he like gets
carted out yeah
um what was your like you remember like
your first relationship growing up what
was that like what do you mean like
dating and stuff was that tough for you
as a kid or were you pretty good at it
no I wasn't good at it um I didn't
realize you weren't supposed to tell
girls how much you liked them because in
movies that's what the uh that's what
the hero would do is he'd be like I love
you so much and they'd be like oh my God
no other guy at school talks this way
right so I thought okay you got to be
like that
you got to be like these John Cusack
types who tell you how they're feeling
and no one really likes that yeah no one
likes that yeah it's too alarming for
people the reality of these two Army for
people but that was also like again like
romanticizing
romance I was just like like no one had
I brought a heaviness to that that I
think people were like this is you gotta
relax this is you know making out in
winter coats here yeah yeah this is not
anything that serious you don't need to
be making speeches yeah yeah the train
isn't leaving the station yeah yeah and
this isn't Casablanca or something yeah
you need to like yeah we're gonna share
a menthol and then hook up standing up
yeah like you need to bring it down a
notch with this monologue
did you how did yeah what was your first
cage at the end of family exactly yeah
at the end of the family man have you
seen that is that where he can choose
between the two paths he's got we got
weatherman jersey she's teal yeah yeah
yeah we've got two kids Annie and Josh
yeah and he like explains to her what
their life is like if she doesn't get on
that plane you can always go to Paris
just not tonight
god dude is that a good one man I
haven't seen it in some time it's good
man
it'll make you believe in something
what was your first relationship
mine this girl
um
this girl was like kind of doing BJs at
school and she liked me right and I
didn't it was like she was really funny
that's what I liked about her but she
was also doing BJs right and people were
and nobody was doing them sure and so
it was kind of nervous because I I liked
her right I really liked her because she
was really funny and she was really cute
but then the doing BJ's part I kind of I
liked that sure but I also was
embarrassed in a way because I didn't
want people like people were like kind
of like you know other people were
judging her because she was doing BJ's
like real early and you thought they
would just they thought your motives
would you thought your motives for
hanging out with her would be suspect
right and I thought that they would
judge me somehow I've always
um
I've always
been like
I've always taken on the response a bit
or taking on the paint or the Judgment
that other people put on somebody that I
have attached to me in a weird way
Uh Oh you mean you get um I get offended
or I get like embarrassed oh wow for
like something that like uh somebody
else will do that I attach myself to
it's really I do that too I think I do
that too it's really not fair I had a
girlfriend that used to she wouldn't
know where people were like we were
standing around somewhere she had bad
peripheral vision and yeah the worst
dude it was unbelievable
so she would always we'd be talking
beautiful girl I loved her but she'd
always like walk right back when
somebody was walking I'm just like and
it ruined it for me oh wow you felt her
embarrassment was she herself
embarrassed not that much oh interesting
so you weren't even feeling her
embarrassment you were just feeling the
only embarrassment yeah it was almost
like the universe had to give it to
someone and she was unaware yeah but I
would take it on though and I would
always be like I'm not gonna let you be
a reflection of how people see me
no matter who that was and I think that
probably goes back to my childhood I was
very embarrassed in my situation that I
was in or something about it made me
uncomfortable so that's how I behave
still it's on it's it's not fair to
other people you know but then you also
like
use the way you grew up
and those things and now you know that
they're of interest to talk about right
well it's a big part of my still
operating you know so it's like some
stuff I still have to really work on I
think you know or look at I see but only
recently in the past five years have I
noticed how all these things play a role
in my life yeah
um but yeah that first relationship so
yeah and then once so we went to a party
one night and everybody knew that I was
gonna Maybe
you know she was gonna do a BJ on me or
whatever okay so we picked like this
tree to do it behind right and did you
talk to her about it yeah we kind of I
think written letters at school about
that specifically Yeah okay or talk to a
friend you know her best friend like
it's gonna happen sure so I'm so nervous
dude I remember I would barely even go
over here we're probably in seventh or
eighth grade okay wow
and I remembered as being so nervous
dude uh
yeah I could barely even walk over there
and I get by the tree and then
we like barely even said any words you
know and then
she might have felt a responsibility to
do it now because we planned it you know
I don't even know well you'd exchange
many letters over it yeah
yeah and then she starts doing it and
then the girl's mom whose party house it
was like we're behind a tree so the only
thing you can't see is the actual kind
of BJ and you can see me and her okay
and then the girl's mom came out and
busted us and it was so and she was uh
it was just so embarrassing
um it made me oh
I just felt so much embarrassment I
think for yourself
I think for both of us you know but what
yeah what she's doing is embarrassing me
but then I'm also here you know I'm it
I'm here too you were definitely part of
it you were half of it you might say
so anyway that was I think you know I
had some early uncomfort with that
uh
uh and just the fact that I loved I felt
like I kind of loved this girl yeah and
other people thought that there was
something wrong with her uh-huh and so I
think that made me some you know I don't
know I think it did something to me a
little bit but changed your perception
of her
yeah and it just made it changed how it
made me often of like really conscious
of what people thought of who
I attached myself to and do you still
have that today I think I do still have
some of it yeah yeah it's kind of
unhealthy well but it's okay I just you
know it's something I think I got to go
through some different you know work on
it more and that's fine
but
yeah it's all okay man you know it's all
okay yeah
yeah
um John Mulaney is there anything else
that you wanted to talk about
um I don't want to take up too much of
your time
because we've chatted for a while I
think I want to ask what does Baby J
mean
because where are you calling your tour
from scratch yeah
the tour I was just on is called from
was called from scratch just because I
started calling these shows I did two
months out of rehab I started doing
these shows at uh City Winery in New
York and I just called it from scratch
and there might have been I was trying
to uh say like all of this is new and
please come to the shows but it's gonna
be rusty
and it's going to be all worked out and
messy and Etc and then I just kept
calling the tour from scratch I never
loved the name but uh
uh
I didn't want to think of a new one
there was too much going on
there's too much going on in early
sobriety and I I didn't you know
I just I just kept going with it
but the special is called Baby J which
is something I refer to myself as
special because the people like when 40
year old men call themselves Baby Jake
people find that really cute and like
that a lot yeah yeah do you think is it
like about being like a late bloomer
what is it what what is it kind of in
relation to I don't know I just refer to
myself as it at one point in the special
and it makes me laugh a lot oh nice
um but a part of it is trying to get
back to that before time
like something
a lot of the a lot of the
um tour I just did we used my first
grade photo as the like tour art
and I mean it just was
uh it was it was like you and I were
talking about it but trying to get back
to that age where there was just like
electricity and things were really
exciting yeah and
some you know something went off track
some some things got darker and
now I'm now I was sober and
uh
so much of my life had changed and I was
out on the road and I was just I was
like I liked seeing that poster of
myself I liked seeing that photo of me
in first grade outside the venue like it
just put me like okay we're trying to
get we're trying to get back to that
we're getting something started chasing
us after that time hmm
something started chasing us that's
interesting yeah yeah that was a thought
I had in rehab like I don't mean like I
hurt well I sort of Heard a Voice but it
said we've been after you since you were
a little kid
and I felt like something yeah something
something's been
things of things have had there's been
many great moments but something
's been trying to get your attention
or to get you to get me wow
you think it's like a disease or
something I don't know
just some we've been after you
we've been after you since you were a
kid we I didn't care for the Wii yeah
listen I didn't like hearing voices and
detox
I didn't like grinding my teeth I
cracked a molar it was a whole crazy but
yeah I didn't I didn't care for the
voice but if I'm gonna hear a voice I
don't like the Wii of it yeah that's a
lot of people yeah that means yeah
there's a van now you know there's a van
that implies bats guys driving around
with bats how bad how bad is detoxing I
never had to do something like that is
it really hard uh benzodiazeprine which
is Xanax and Klonopin that detox really
sucks and do you stay in a room what do
you do
um I stayed in D so some people go to
detox for a couple days I was there for
five or six days
um
they try to taper you off uh with this
medication called Librium which I don't
know if that's a benzo anyway it's
similar but
um
yeah the first of that week I was sort
of in a medicated detox and then the
second week was like
my skeleton wanted to rip out of my body
wow yeah
and does it and they said that they were
like those are the most
um
no not like ow pain mine mine felt like
I cannot
be like I cannot sit it's not even like
I remember laying on my bed just like
[__] writhing just like I no every
part of me wants to rip into wow
but they said that when I got there
they're like Coke is not I mean Coke was
my problem but they said Coke isn't your
problem these the benzos the downers is
gonna be the real Beast yeah yeah
could you do an eight ball in a day you
think
yeah
wow
I mean
I don't say that like maybe it would
take a what was a day also Define a day
that's true that's your joke maybe a day
and a half yeah if you're up for 24
hours that eight ball dang dude
I would I remember sometimes I couldn't
even inhale anymore yeah yeah that that
feeling of uh I also I would feel like
vibrating so much but I remember times
when I
felt like
okay I've done too much like this is
serious and I've done too much and maybe
I should go down to my Lobby
and sit there in case I need to get I
lived right near right next to an urgent
care that's great I was like maybe I
need to sit here and just tell the
doorman to grab a paramedic or something
uh
but there were a couple nights where I
just thought I've done too much but I'm
then I would still be crashing so
physically I'm like
um this is we've done way too much coke
I can't feel my legs I'm totally like
this is a real disaster and then
mentally I'd start crashing a little and
be like I need to do can I do another
bump
is there a way for to do a bump that
would satisfy this but not affect the
oncoming
uh
Cardiac Arrest we're about to have
so isn't that crazy we would think that
you're in such a balancing act you're in
such a go you know what if I'm gonna go
to the hospital I probably should do a
line first yeah yeah
they'd want me to just so I'm talkative
yeah yeah
there yeah they would want you to that's
so interesting you on the road now yeah
what do I have doing I got some shows in
Phoenix next week oh nice oh yeah I'm
excited about that I yeah you know I
started my tour kind of like
I I should have had my show more mapped
out before I put it up into some like
smaller theaters you know yeah so
sometimes I feel a little bit bad about
that I thought it was why did they feel
Rocky yeah they just felt a little rocky
well you know but
I just always want to make sure that I
give the you know of course but you're
trying to put on the best show you could
right I was trying for sure yeah only
the other route would be to just what
stay and do weekends at clubs yeah yeah
that would have been probably the a
route that would have been just
to better service the hour you know yeah
I get that yeah I think but sometimes
people are like come Out Come perform
well sometimes you have a couple great
shows and you go this is ready for
theaters and then you get there and
you're like this is yeah wow these
people paid money and yeah yeah and it
wasn't bad it was just and we have high
no expectations of course you have very
high expectations of yourself of course
yeah when I'm out there at the very
beginning figuring out an hour and I'm
like this is actually 40 minutes with 20
minutes of filler it's I I feel very I I
I work hard at the news I work hard at
what I can and I hope that I have enough
Charisma to pull off
the whole that that no one's noticing
that this is you know padded yeah
man yeah I think you got a ton well also
it's like you go back on the road after
you've just done a special so you what
you the last memory you have is this
product that was like finely tuned yeah
and now you're out there you know
doing stuff about how big the Denver
Airport is yeah because you just landed
in Denver yeah I remember the Char I had
a show in Charleston and literally the
next night I had my I had an hour that
came out and so the next night I knew
this is when you have to turn over when
you can't do
material that's on the special you have
to kind of turn over you know most of it
and do new stuff and that was a tough
weekend because the first show was
pretty awesome and or and the second one
was not it was just kind of like [__]
yeah well that's the thing it's like
you can just hit all green lights one
night and be like I have a new 15
minutes and yeah I don't you have
nothing yeah
you have one
um when you do like a first CD
like did you make like a comedy album
yeah unrelated to a not a TV yeah yeah I
did that too and I thought when that
came out I can never do any of these
jokes again wow no one [__] listened
to it yeah
I wish I was I remember going out to do
was I just starting to headline maybe I
I think I was gonna headline the Houston
livestop
and I had a CD that was out and I was
like well if anyone's heard the CD
they'd know that know these jokes so I
got to do a whole new hour oh no you
didn't no absolutely no one had heard
this album
no and some guys you can just do that's
one to mess something about putting
things out it's like if you never put
things out then you would just be this
thing that people can only go see if
they go see you yeah I think about that
I think about like the Grateful Dead
model too yeah I was like I wish I could
make every show different and tour like
that and you probably could never I
guess so
well I think a lot I mean what you need
to do is you need to get like three
hours of stuff and then you just
sample between it which some people do I
get do you think people come to see you
or your material oh I don't know
um
I think the material because if you
don't have it in
um
like if if I don't have it in the first
10 minutes in the first five minutes
it's not that fun yeah that's true for
anybody huh I don't know I mean in an
arena I don't know maybe they're coming
just for the maybe some people come for
the like
this is cool of it you know but
especially there no what am I saying I
think it's all for the jokes yeah yeah
people want to be entertained for sure I
think at a certain point though people
kind of get to know you especially
probably after this special comes out
yeah we're gonna get to know maybe more
just about some of your journey there's
a lot in it you get to know me pretty
well so that I mean I think letting
people get to know you
uh that's you know it's important and
then they know you you know they get to
you yeah it's it's all fun them getting
to know one side of you and right and
then you go okay also sometimes I'm not
a great guy oh yeah
yeah that happens a lot to all of us
um
so you're out now
yeah yeah I'm out and I just do sporadic
like I was doing like a night and a
night and a night in different cities
yeah and now I'm doing more like kind of
smaller venues but staying in a city for
five nights that's the best way to do it
I agree I just did the arena thing and
that was awesome but you are hitting a
point where uh more you can do more
nights at a theater more people will
come see you uh
over more people will find out you're in
town yeah and you do like an eight night
run or so I did that down in Atlanta and
Philly Nashville too someone said I did
um
I think it was four or five nights at
the Ryman
that was really fun yeah I was on my
40th birthday too really yeah I thought
you were younger than that man you look
younger that was a cool that's a cool
room that Ryan isn't it the greatest
yeah oh my God it's the greatest yeah
it's awesome and the Wilbur is really
awesome too huh The Wilbur is really fun
God the Wilbur is good Wilbur really you
feel the energy there with Bill uh
blumen right yeah he's the greatest yeah
he's got the best stories too yeah he
does he's got Foxwoods too and yeah he's
got the best stories
um what other goals you have in your
future I know you have the amazing
animation
right is that your series which one
um big mouth yeah yeah I'm on that yeah
um sorry I know I know that no that's
okay uh
that's created by Nick Kroll and Andrew
Goldberg and uh
Mark and Jen
um the flacketts and they're great and
uh yeah we do that now do you have other
stuff that you feel like you like
creatively that you're like haven't done
like worked in television created shows
do you feel like stand up is really the
best media you do it's the most most fun
best delivery service of Comedy it's
yeah
that it's Freebase it's yeah yeah dude
it's the best possible situation in
terms of delivering it's Freebase yeah
it's grimy yeah yeah it's a little
grimier than TV yeah yeah did you ever
end up in a really cool place doing
drugs
uh meaning the geographic Place yeah
just like a dicey like you know shonies
or something you know some place that
was a little deviant you know
um karaoke bar
I'm trying to think like were you that
were you that guy that wanted to get
deep into the Trap houses and [__] were
you like kind of like the um
uh who was the guy Anthony Bourdain of
like trap houses and stuff like that
did Anthony what's a trap house a trap
house is just like a place where people
are doing drugs and there's like a lady
who's like probably like you know if you
wake her up she would have sex maybe
like in the back it's like Anthony
Bourdain went to these no he didn't but
he was like food places he went to
restaurants yeah right are you like that
was not there
uh yeah are you like would you be that
guy like was that kind of your like some
people like to get into the depths of
the of the 5 a.m you know and like just
the like how weird can I get no my the
weirdest times for me were the days
because I was
I mean that feeling of
you know when you haven't slept and the
whole world has yeah just the way that
that warmth you feel in your bones you
know going into Starbucks or like
man like just running an errand and
you're like does everyone know can
everyone tell there's just something
kind of like shinier about us yeah you
know like
something like sleeker we're just a
faster animal because like we didn't
just lay down for eight hours
oh I'm sure you are more alert huh oh
you're like an alley cat
like an alley cat
yeah and you're like a [__] very but
you're like but things also become far
more complicated right
oh I would overthink things overthink
everything you're like a ghost you're
like a fast [__] like a Tesla ghost
and you're like these clothes don't look
like someone put them on this morning
yeah these look like yesterday clothes
yeah not even at their wrinkle not even
anything just you just have an air about
you that says I did not just rest yeah
but I think no one can tell
if you're still gacked up enough to
converse
yeah
[__] I would be so scared dude I would
walk
yeah my depth perception would feel
weird yeah it's a lot of like cat you
know cars everything's coming in yeah
everything's coming fast oh
god dude they're a disaster how yeah
drugs are a disaster and that's a nice
thing to not have to worry about anymore
isn't it oh my God
yeah that is not I'm not in a crisis all
the time yeah
did you end up getting help at like did
you go to recovery after that did you go
to 12 step or you just kind of went to
um I was in
two rehabs I was in sober living I did
12 step but you know with sober living
pretty cool
sober living was uh for a couple months
after rehab I can't imagine going from
rehab to to living on my own yeah that
would have been
no I I really needed as many training
wheels as possible wow so you really
went through it all yeah
I mean no I mean or uh
I mean through it all I mean not like
you you went through the the things that
people go through yeah that was a moment
where I I really needed to get as like
um
textbook as possible right because I
would have told you like okay I can I
can go live on my own now
I've just been in I've been in this
place for two months and I'm clean but
it's like you're clean because you've
been in rehab right
but I would have thought like I actually
I I had a lot of good and I had a lot of
Great Moments in treatment really did
had great counselor and um great people
but like the actual reason that I wasn't
on drugs was because I was in central
Pennsylvania living in a hospital yeah
you know was it nice out there was it
pretty
[Music]
um
it was a winter it was a little desolate
but sometimes it was quite
sometimes it's quite beautiful
did they have any horses or anything
like that no um I wish we had had some
of that you know
getting to put a shoe on a horse or
whatever they have drug addicts do crazy
yeah
like you're petting them like okay I
have a joke in this special about I feel
so bad for that horse because it thinks
it's going to win the Kentucky Derby but
then it's just drug addicts being like
okay
all right petting your strong leg gives
me confidence I remember seeing this
whenever I saw your set
um John Mulaney thanks so much giovan
thanks for having me dude it's awesome
man it was great to talk to you yeah you
too man I uh really admire you and your
ability dude I really admire you man
it's it's uh very nice to have a
conversation with you say man and you're
dude when you get on stage man it is I
want to know what you were gonna do and
say same 100 I want you to know that
just as a I am excited that you're up
there thanks man I'm excited when you're
up there yeah thanks Sean I envy what
you have man it's amazing you too man
and uh yeah check out the new special
um April 25th April 25th and we'll post
about it I'll put a post up on my social
media too man to make sure not that you
don't already have your own humongous
audience but uh take yours too okay
awesome we'll be happy to share thank
you
[Music]
I can feel it in my bones
gonna take